Ja, Leute, ich bin heute wieder ziemlich im Arsch.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, wir hatten jetzt einen so schönen Streaming-Streak.
Die letzten Tage habe ich gedacht, komm, so eineinhalb Stunden am Abend.
Das kriegen wir jetzt auch noch gebacken.
Also, Chat, ich muss sagen, ich dachte nicht, dass dieses E-Mode so gut ankommt.
Und wem haben wir es zu verdanken? Ich glaube dem Chainlaw, oder?
Das wird passen. Das wird passen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt ein Chainlaw-E-Mode.
Würde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen. Im Zweifelsfall ist es eins.
Soll ich euch mal...
Der letzte Stream freie Tag war am 3.6.
Wirklich.
Ich habe jetzt quasi eine Woche fast gestreamt am Stück.
Guckst? Nö.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann dir auch sagen, warum ich das nicht gucke,
weil es gab in den letzten Jahren wenig AAA-Games, wo ich gesagt habe,
boah, da freue ich mich voll drauf.
Und das hätte sich gelohnt, da irgendwas zu gucken.
Ich schaue mir eine Zusammenfassung an.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das geht. Bis 22 Uhr oder so, glaube ich.
Und wahrscheinlich sind am Ende eh nur zwei, drei Sachen dabei, die auch ansatzweise spannend sind.
Können wir eine Version mit dem Keks als Sub-E-Mode bekommen?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht echt nicht.
Erstens, weil ich das E-Mode schon ein bisschen grenzwertig finde.
Und zweitens, weil Twitch keine anstößigen Emotes erlaubt.
Das steht sogar extra.
Das steht sogar in den Emote-Bedingungen, die man ankreuzen muss.
Also, dass man keine...
Was übrigens auch nicht erlaubt ist, sind die ganzen Emotes mit Keanu Reeves und sowas.
Weil eigentlich darfst du keine Emotes nehmen mit dem Gesicht von Leuten drauf.
Also, außer sie sind von Twitch und haben da zugestimmt und sowas.
Aber ich meine, wie sagt man, wo kein Kläger ist, da kein...
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wahrscheinlich interessiert es im Endeffekt keinen wirklich.
Ich muss mal kurz die...
Die Wii-Shop oder Wii-Store oder wie auch immer der Kram hieß, Musik ausmachen.
Das wird zu aufträglich auf der...
Der Wii-Shop-Channel, genau.
Ich muss hier irgendwie eins von meinen Standard-Dingern anmachen.
Ach, komm, heute ist was...
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt nicht gucken.
Das auch nicht.
WTF, warum habe ich hier so viel Zeug aus?
So, ja.
Songs and Smiles. Sehr gut.
Moin, Erbsen-Raupe.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal was.
Neues Sophos-Firewall-Einrichtung.
Ja gut, weil man 20.15 Uhr, das ist Primetime.
Da macht man nur die besten Sachen.
Ich zeige mal schnell was für die Leute, die dabei waren, als wir den EPG-Champ programmiert haben.
Ich habe jetzt noch was...
Was gepusht gerade.
Guckst du Summer Games fest?
Ne, ich gucke mir danach irgendeine Zusammenfassung an.
Der Desktop, der Desktop ist massive, pock.
Ich finde alles. Ich habe euch schon oft demonstriert, dass ich alles finde.
Außerdem ist der Desktop noch nicht voll genug,
weil der Explorer bzw. die Startleiste lag.
Noch nicht.
Erst, wenn die Startseite anfängt zu laggen,
dann weißt du, der Desktop ist zu voll.
Hattet ihr das schon mal?
Dass der Desktop so voll war, dass wenn ihr Windows-Taste gedrückt habt,
dass die Windows-Taste erst 8 Sekunden später aufging?
Dazu braucht ihr ungefähr 4x so viele Icons auf dem Desktop.
Das habe ich schon geschafft.
Ich finde es fragwürdig, warum die Icons auf dem Desktop überhaupt beeinflussen,
wie schnell das Startmenü aufgeht.
Aber gut, das ist Microsoft.
Das darf man nicht weiter hinterfragen.
Wenn kein Platz, werden dann die Icons gesteckt.
Ne, Microsoft kann sowas nicht.
Die Icons gehen einfach aus dem Bild raus.
Also wenn du, guck mal, ich zeig's dir.
Ne, also mal angenommen, wir nehmen jetzt hier Pogu,
was auch immer Pogu ist.
Ist das C++?
Als CXT?
Ok, was auch immer.
Das ist Pogu.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt hier weiter einfüge.
Pogu.
Kopie von Pogu mache.
Alter, es laggt schon richtig, Leute.
Also, wenn ich Kopie von Pogu mache, und das mache ich so oft.
Das hört sich ja total bescheuert an.
Also, ich mache jetzt mehrere Kopien von Pogu.
Dann wird das irgendwann leaked.
Da ist überhaupt nichts leaked.
Guck, da ist nichts drin.
Was soll ich denn hier großartig leaken?
Bitteschön.
Irgendwas, was wir eh schon im Stream gemacht haben.
So, ich mache jetzt ganz viel Kopie von Pogu.
Ok.
Und du wirst sehen.
Guck mal, wie langsam das ist.
Ich drücke.
Du wirst sehen, was passiert.
Es passiert nichts.
Es geht einfach aus dem Bildschirm raus.
Also, Microsoft sortiert den Kram einfach weiter hier hinten.
Die haben da keine Logik drin.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz auf meinen Desktop und alle Pogus wieder.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alle Pogus wieder wegschmeißen.
Pogu deleted.
Oh, was ist denn das hier?
Windows XP Professional.
Das kann auch weg.
Ich brauche Platz.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich habe nur noch, ich habe nur noch 11G frei.
Das geht aber nicht.
Ich pull mal kurz ganz schnell, bis das Stream so richtig losgeht.
Ich pull mal kurz die aktuelle Version vom EPG Champ.
Übrigens, wer sich das angucken will, der nicht dabei war.
Hier gibt es das.
Moment.
EPG Champ auf GitHub.
Ich habe es auch alles auf GitHub gepusht.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich dieses Wort richtig geschrieben habe.
Modularizing.
Was auch immer.
Ja.
So, ich pull mal kurz.
Nice is issue.
Keck weh.
Ja ey, dieser Typ, wer auch immer das gewesen ist, der war der Meinung, er muss mich Jibaden
mit einem Recroll Video, wenn man das anklickt.
So.
Ich starte das mal kurz.
Ich habe mir sogar den Start Parameter copy pasted, dass ich das jetzt nicht eintippen
muss.
Ups.
Was mache ich denn?
Backend.
Start.
Rider.
EPG.
Backend.
Ne.
Web.
Open.
Zeige euch mal was.
Ich habe was, ich habe was gemacht.
Musik Toss.
Warum ist die Musik Toss?
Oh.
Ach so.
Ich habe mein NPM Install habe ich vergessen.
Zeige euch mal was.
Ach die vom Issue.
Die vom Issue.
Die ist.
Die darf ich nicht abspielen.
Ja.
Die ist Toss.
So.
Guckt mal.
Ich habe noch eine Sache gemacht.
Erstens lädt der EPG Champ jetzt ein bisschen schneller.
Initial muss er einmal abspielen.
Ja.
Die ist Toss.
So.
Guckt mal.
Initial muss er einmal laden.
Dann backt er ein bisschen rum.
Aber wenn ich jetzt noch mal lade.
Er lädt schneller.
Und.
Ach so.
Das schnellste ist es nicht.
So.
Und jetzt.
Passt mal auf.
Ein bisschen verbuggt ist das ganze schon.
Aber ok.
Wenn ich jetzt.
Ihr seht.
Es gibt Hover.
Hover Effekt.
Hover.
Und wenn man hier drauf klickt.
Dann hat man jetzt ein Dark Theme Popup.
Und auch.
Eins mit ordentlicher Schrift.
Und.
jetzt fast mit dem ersten Jahr durch.
Könnte nicht glücklich sein. Das ist doch schön.
Das heißt, du hast mal eine Abschlussprüfung.
Schon weitere News
wegen der Arbeit. Ja, tatsächlich.
Uns wurde heute auf der Arbeit
erzählt, wie das laufen soll. Also mein
aktueller Chef ist anscheinend weg.
Was ich blöd finde,
weil mit dem habe ich mich gut verstanden. Ich finde auch, der hat das
gut gemacht.
Warum? Keine Ahnung.
Will ich jetzt hier nichts zu erzählen und kann
man im Endeffekt auch bloß mutmaßen.
Aber wir kriegen jemanden Neues.
Das ist wohl
noch die
beste Wahl, die man treffen konnte
für uns. Weil alle anderen Alternativen
wären wirklich hochgradig nervig gewesen.
Aber ich bin eh gespannt, was
kommt. Also ich habe in
einer Woche
ungefähr.
Das weiß man noch nicht.
Aber das würde ich jetzt hier auch nicht erzählen.
So.
In einer Woche habe ich dann zum ersten Mal Gespräch
mit meinem neuen Chef. Und da muss ich
den gleich fragen, wie sieht es mit Homeoffice aus.
Weil ganz im Ernst, es hat ja
keinen Sinn, wenn
ich da mit denen jetzt die große Planung mache
und dann kommt am Ende raus, es gibt
kein Homeoffice und ich kündige.
Das wäre ja bescheuert. Also ich muss den gleich fragen,
was mit Homeoffice ist. Und wenn die sagen, geht
nicht, dann kann ich bloß nochmal sagen,
überlegt es euch vielleicht nochmal.
Weil aus diesen und diesen Gründen und wenn nicht,
dann bin ich weg.
Du meinst, dass man eine Genre-Anzeige neben macht?
Das Problem ist, die Genres, also
die Beschreibung,
ist ziemlich doof. Guck, zum Beispiel
ist die,
kannst du ja mal schnell zeigen, warte mal.
Also die Genre-Beschreibung
ist ziemlich, ziemlich
dämlich.
Nämlich, warte mal.
Guck mal, also die Genre-Beschreibungen
sind teilweise nicht so kurz.
Ach ne, man sieht es ja nicht richtig. Die sind richtig blöd aus.
Die Genre-Beschreibungen sind da sowas wie
Drama, Mufi, Soap
und sowas. Also
die sind ziemlich, ziemlich
Müll.
Schaut der neue Chef auch, ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Also mein aktueller Chef, von dem weiß ich,
den habe ich sogar schon mal im Stream gesehen.
So im Chat habe ich nichts zu gesagt.
Aber der neue nicht, ne, ne.
Glaube ich nicht, dass der Twitch guckt.
Ich habe es gesehen, ja. Ich habe es sogar schon runtergeladen,
aber ich hatte heute keine Nerven mehr,
das Ganze zu spielen.
Ich gucke mir das morgen an.
Vielleicht mache ich auch ein Video zu. Übrigens, Leute,
mein aktuelles Video, ja,
das hätte ich gar nicht, was habe ich denn da auf?
Ach, den Fallinformatiker
Plan. Mein aktuelles Video,
das kommt richtig gut an.
Ich habe das hochgeladen vorhin,
hat jetzt schon über, die Anzahl geht jetzt nicht ganz richtig,
hat glaube ich schon mittlerweile 13.000
Aufrufe oder so. Aber ich gucke mal kurz rein
bei mir.
Im YouTube-Channel.
Zack.
Bin ich nicht eingeloggt?
Kann das sein?
Alter, ich will mein Profil nicht generaten.
Was ist denn das wieder für ein Crap?
Ich kann mich nicht bei Google einloggen, weil
ich mit einem anderen Account eingeloggt bin
und ich jetzt nicht YouTube aufmachen darf.
Okay.
Sign out.
Jetzt YouTube aufmachen. Ich gucke mal kurz.
Aber ich glaube, es war irgendwas um 13.000
Views mittlerweile schon.
Ah, ne. Okay, kann ich nicht machen.
Oder? Kann ich das doch machen?
Wartet mal.
Max FPS. Next.
Next.
Two-Step-Authentification.
Boah, ne.
Ich bleibe jetzt ausgeloggt.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, das Handy zu holen.
Gar nicht.
Aber ich glaube, es hat irgendwas um 13.000
Views schon. Das ist wirklich gut angekommen.
Und ich glaube, ich habe da auch den Nerv getroffen
bei manchen. Ich muss aber sagen,
ganz im Ernst, was da manche Leute
widerschreiben, ist
widerstreben.
Haha. Ich habe die geilste
Einladung überhaupt gerade gegeben.
Sehe ich ja gerade auf dem Handy erst.
Lull. Das ist geil. Okay, das muss ich euch erzählen.
Moment. Ich habe
gerade eine Einladung bekommen, die sich
nennt.
Moment. Ich muss den Service
ein bisschen
umbenennen, weil man sonst weiß,
um was es geht, weil in dem Service quasi der Name
von meinem Arbeitgeber drin ist.
Deswegen so ein weiterer Micro-
Service oder was auch immer, was sie da haben.
Zumindest, da steht
drinne. Okay, wie nenne ich das Ding jetzt?
Okay, ich weiß, wie ich es nenne. Also, ich habe
Einladung bekommen. HTTPS
Test Easy Server.
So.
In Wirklichkeit heißt das anders. Und wisst ihr,
was der Witz ist?
Also, das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht
wild, aber
heute Nacht um 23 Uhr
wird der Easy Server
live geschaltet.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der Sinn ist,
diesen Service zum ersten Mal
morgen um 11 zu testen. Das hätten sie
vielleicht ein bisschen früher machen sollen, oder?
Ich meine ja nur,
ich meine ja nur, also wenn der
heute Abend 23 Uhr live geschaltet wird, hätte man
den sich vielleicht mal die letzte Woche
angucken sollen oder sowas und nicht erst
morgen um 11 testen. Was ist das denn schon
wieder für ein Rumgefusche,
Mann?
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz hier
Musik ein bisschen leiser.
Nein, nein, nein, ich wollte nicht Steve Jobs
anklingen. Musik leiser.
Sekunde. Tests immer
nach dem Release, ja? Alter, die Leute
teilweise bei uns. Echter Wahnsinn.
Wir testen das
morgen um 11. Bin mal gespannt.
Das war eh wieder typischer Business
Stonkskrempel, ohne Scheiß.
Wir haben ja eigentlich mittlerweile
relativ gut dokumentierte Prozesse,
wenn was Neues eingeführt
werden soll.
Problem ist nur,
die Leute halten sich dann letztendlich
nicht dran. Und das sind die gleichen Leute, die damals
mitgemacht haben beim Einführen dieser Prozesse.
Zumindest. Es gibt
laut unserem
Change-Prozess ein
Umsetzungsdatum. Das ist
zwingend erforderlich, dass da ein Umsetzungsdatum
drin ist. Also sprich, wann geplant ist, wann das
Ganze live gehen soll. Und da steht drin,
28.06. Und ich hab das
dementsprechend auch geplant. Ja, ich hab mir gedacht,
gut, ich baue das jetzt mal ein, bei uns ins
Konfliktmanagement. Da probieren wir das mal
aus. Und letzte Woche Freitag,
Freitags auch, da muss man sich mal vorstellen,
letzte Woche Freitags
ruft mich da mein Chef an und
hat irgendjemand
von der
Anwendungsentwicklung in der Leitung und meinte,
ja, wie weit wäre das Ganze denn?
Derjenige, der das koordiniert,
der ist ja krank, vielleicht wissen wir was.
Ja, 28.06.
Ganz normal,
sobald quasi
Konfliktmanagement mal wieder läuft
mit den neuesten Changes, dann ist das
da, dann testen wir das.
Umgebung, dann ist das so in
zwei Wochen oder so, ist das dann
soweit live, dass ihr das ausprobieren könnt.
Und dann meint sie, nein, nein, das reicht nicht.
Wie, das reicht nicht? Ich denke,
28.06. Dann meinte sie,
nein, nein, 10.06.
Da denke ich mir auch, wozu haben wir
diese Prozesse und Abläufe, wenn sich
keine Sau dran hält, ja?
Da hab ich jetzt noch irgendwas
hingefrickelt.
Also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, ich hab
irgendwas hingewurstet. Das ist so schlimm,
Leute, müsst ihr euch vorstellen. Ich hab auf
diesem Server jetzt extra, damit es funktioniert,
weil wir, also, normalerweise,
dass du intern auf Server zugreifen
kannst, ist das so, du musst bei uns
über irgendeinen Loadbalancer, der das dann weiter
verteilt. So. Nachdem
wir allerdings nicht
jetzt mal nebenbei uns da
neue Loadbalancer-Config aus dem Ärmel schütteln
können, haben wir es jetzt so gemacht, ich benutze
den alten Port, der
schon Loadbalanced wird und installiere
ein Reverse-Proxy auf diesem
Port, der es auf die neue,
äh, auf die neue, äh,
auf das neue Ziel, Reverse-Proxy-Loadbalance,
dann nochmal weiter.
Also, also sprich,
der Loadbalancer loadbalanced
auf den alten Port, auf dem alten
Port ist allerdings gar nicht mehr der Service,
wo das eigentlich rauskommen soll,
sondern da läuft jetzt ein Reverse-Proxy,
der das Ganze annimmt und dann auf den
eigentlichen Service weiterleitet.
Ich sag euch doch, ich hab richtig hingefrickelt.
Und wisst ihr, und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Es ist nicht etwa so, dass
dieser, also da hab ich übrigens den hier genommen,
den wir,
äh, auch schon öfters eben im Stream verwendet haben,
ja? Also ich finde,
ease of use und, und sonst was ist
Kadi wirklich wunderbar, vor allem, weil das
als einzelnes Go-Binary, ne, ich kann,
ich hatte jetzt nicht die Zeit irgendwie
bei uns ins Repo neue RPM-Packages
zu packen oder sowas. Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt gemacht
hab? Das ist ernsthaft kein Witz.
Ich hab jetzt WGET gemacht,
auf alle Server,
also auch auf produktive Server,
WGET gemacht, Kadi runtergeladen,
Config
angelegt,
TMAX-Session gestartet
und jetzt läuft unter meinem User
in meiner TMAX-Session
ein Kadi im Vordergrund,
im Terminal, der produktive Service
ist loadbalanced, damit wir keine
Loadbalancer-Anpassungen brauchen, damit es bis zum
10.06. durch ist.
Also, wenn diesen Server irgendjemand
neu startet, ist eh vorbei.
Dann wird wir dem Leben
nicht wieder hochkommen und funktionieren.
Also, das ist wirklich,
aber hey, ich hab's gesagt, ja?
Ich hab's gesagt und letztendlich,
die wollen das, also der
Koordinator hat gesagt, ja,
mach das so, sogar
der Koordinator, ich hab's gescreenshottet,
ohne Scheiß, ich hab's gescreenshottet, hat zu mir
gesagt, ja, dieser Easy-Service,
dieser Easy-Server,
der ist nicht so wichtig und
wenn es mal dann nicht kurz
ausruckelt oder so, ist nicht
schlimm. Ich hab mir diese Aussage extra
gescreenshottet und dass das okay ist,
wie ich das gemacht hab, dass man das im Nachgang dann
alles fixen kann und da bin
ich, bin ich mal gespannt,
was dabei rauskommt jetzt.
Oh man,
der tägliche Business, Business-Stocks-
Enterprise-Umfeld-Wahnsinn.
Genau, es
darf maximal drei Millisekunden ruckeln,
ja? Ich mein,
wenn man sich anguckt, was wir
teilweise für krasse SLAs bezahlen
und
es weder brauchen
noch kontrollieren, ob
die sogar eingehalten werden, weiß ich nicht,
also die schmeißen gerne, ja gut,
das ist ne Bank, die haben genug Geld, ja?
Die schmeißen gerne Geld zum Fenster raus.
TheCodeMonkey82,
Dankeschön für den
Primesub.
Hast du dir das unterschreiben lassen? Naja, ich hab ihn gefragt,
den das koordiniert, der hat gesagt, ja, ich hab
mir einen Screenshot von gemacht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand ernsthaft
dort argumentieren wird, ich hätte den Screenshot
gefälscht.
Und wenn, und wenn das wirklich einer sagt,
dann mach ich wirklich.
Und wisst ihr, und wisst ihr, wenn das
einer sagt, dann mute ich mich einfach,
und spiele nur noch
Ab und geh raus.
Weil das kann ich mir
nicht wirklich vorstellen, dass das einer behaupten würde,
ich hätte den Teamscreenshot gefälscht.
Wie geht's dem Unraid?
Das, ähm,
steht hinter mir im Serverraum und
unraidet vor sich hin.
Es läuft noch nicht alles komplett drauf,
aber es ist an und surft
und macht das,
wofür es da ist.
The most epic
GitHub-Pullregion.
The quest of all time.
Das hab ich gesehen, dass das irgendein Typ
der Epic Games GitHub
für die Unreal Engine
was reingepackt hat und hat irgendwie
250.000 Leute
angeschrieben, aus Versehen.
Was ich nicht gut fand ist,
wie, wie, keine Ahnung,
hasserfüllt teilweise die Antworten der Leute
da waren. Ich mein, ganz im Ernst,
vielleicht ist es einfach jemand, der keinen Plan hat, was er da gemacht hat.
Oder 54.000,
weiß ich nicht, da haben sich die Leute wieder aufgespielt.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ist das so schlimm, wenn du,
irgendwie, 50 Benachrichtigungen
kriegst, kriegst du 51 Benachrichtigungen,
ja, und Leute, die eh wenig Benachrichtigungen kriegen,
die verkraften es trotzdem. Also,
ich seh, ich seh das nicht so wild.
Wenn ich mir überlege, ich hab's auf der Arbeit ja
mittlerweile so gemacht,
meine E-Mail-Inbox,
die wird
quasi gar nicht mehr direkt
benutzt, in der bleibt alles drin,
ich guck in meine Inbox auch nicht mehr rein,
ich hab einen Filter,
der geht, alles, was
direkt an mich geht, oder an mich
im CC,
geht in einen Ordner an mich,
und dann hab ich noch was, was an den
Teamverteiler geht, das geht in einen Ordner
Team. Der Rest bleibt
ungelesen in der Inbox, und
es ist schon öfters mal vorgekommen, dass
die Leute mich fragen, Max, was ist denn los,
hast du das nicht gesehen? Da muss ich sagen,
ups, übersehen, weil
ich blick sonst nicht mehr durch.
Das ist so, ja, ja, du musst
der Epic GitHub Gruppe
beitreten, wenn du bei Unreal irgendwie
in
die Docs oder in den
Source Code gucken willst, glaube,
was auch immer.
Kündigung übersehen, deswegen müssen
Kündigungen immer schriftlich zugestellt werden.
Und nicht per Mail.
Aber, ja, ich mein, wenn man die Kündigung übersehen könnte,
wäre es ja easy, dann könnte man da einfach immer
sagen, was? Na, das hab ich
nicht gesehen, jetzt müssen wir leider noch mal drei Monate
warten. Das ist richtig
bescheuert gemacht, SiriusMax, da hast du recht.
Schon auf, ja, ich hab
auf die neueste Version geupgradet.
Warum? Achso, nee, aber ob's die
allerneueste, das war ja aber die neueste Major-Version,
auf die hab ich schon geupgradet, ja.
Gut, ähm, Leute, wir, wir, heute,
ich hab gestern so viel geschwätzt hier
im Stream. Ich, äh,
hab gar kein großartiges
Schwätzmaterial mehr.
Wir machen morgen,
kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen,
morgen machen wir entweder
den, noch ein bisschen weiter am
EPG-Champ, ich bin mir da gar nicht wirklich sicher,
was wir von beiden machen, also entweder,
also wir haben drei Sachen zur Auswahl morgen.
Wir könnten,
theoretisch, eine Abstimmung machen.
Was haltet ihr davon? Wir machen eine Abstimmung,
wir könnten eine Abstimmung machen, was wir,
was wir morgen im Stream machen. Und zwar,
ähm,
wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen am EPG-Champ
machen.
Also sprich, das ist dann im Endeffekt, äh,
.NET und, und JavaScript programmieren.
Nein, Diablo spielen wir nicht.
Das geb ich mir nicht
weiter, äh. Also, das ist
die erste Auswahl. Wir könnten, äh,
Svelte, JavaScript, ähm,
C-Sharp, ASP.NET Core,
programmieren.
EPG-Champ.
Wir könnten, also alles Sachen,
die, die ich, die, die wir noch machen müssen.
Das nächste ist, wir machen den
Zabbix weiter, oder wie die coolen Leute sagen,
der Zabbix. Wir machen den Zabbix
weiter, weil es gibt noch ein paar Sachen, die ich
ausprobieren will. Unter anderem, meine
Internetverbindung überwachen, also quasi im Hintergrund
regelmäßig mal einen Speedcheck machen,
dass ich mir einen schönen Graph malen kann.
Wie gut ist denn
Vodafone, auch wenn man nicht gerade
aktiv nachkommt,
guckt und, äh, noch
Kisten bei mir hinzufügen, die ich hier im Haus habe.
Gucke, wie man Access-Points ordentlich überwacht.
Äh, es kommt noch mehr Zabbix.
Ja, wie gesagt, steht zur Auswahl. Danke
für deinen Sub. Äh, also, äh,
Zabbix weitermachen, steht zur Auswahl.
Und das dritte ist,
ähm, wir machen,
wir machen gleich eine Umfrage. Irgendeiner der Mods,
falls einer da ist, macht, macht gleich eine Umfrage, wenn ich
erklärt hab, was es alles gibt. Und, ähm,
das dritte ist,
Rust WebAssembly.
Okay.
Das will ich,
das will ich mir lange Zeit schon mal angucken.
Aber,
ich hab bisher
noch nicht so wirklich den,
den Aufhänger gefunden, warum ich das mal
machen will. Also, mir schwebt ja vor,
mir schwebt ja vor Folgendes.
Ich würde gerne FFM-Pack
im Browser verwenden.
Und zwar über WebAssembly.
Warum Rust?
Man, wir könnten auch
C++ machen.
Da ist mir Rust aber lieber.
Also, ich glaube, Rust ist für WebAssembly
ganz cool.
Gerade auch in Kombination mit Packages,
die es dafür schon gibt.
Und es muss wohl, also es gibt viele gute Tutorials
und es muss wohl relativ einfach sein,
sowohl Bindings zu erstellen,
dass man das Ganze von JavaScript coilen kann.
Es gibt wohl schon viele fertige Packages und auch
die Tools muss das
quasi schon
out of the box alles integriert sein.
Ja, du kannst sogar .NET WebAssembly
machen, ich weiß.
Das letzte Mal war das aber ziemlicher Paintschamp.
Ich hoffe, dass das besser wird mit
ihrer neuen Ahead of Time Compilation,
die ja noch ein bisschen eklig ist.
Ja, übrigens, das sage ich euch auch gleich dazu.
Ihr kennt mich, wenn ich morgen, also mal angenommen,
es gewinnt jetzt Zappix oder so mit 100 Stimmen.
Ich behalte mir vor, wenn ich morgen gar keinen Bock
drauf habe, vielleicht was anderes zu machen
oder auch gar nicht zu streamen.
Aber ich denke, ich halte mich dran.
Ja, wir machen alle drei Sachen.
Wir machen alle drei Sachen.
Aber es ist ja nur die Frage, was wir morgen machen wollen.
Okay.
Es sieht nach Rust WebAssembly aus.
Oh, das wird Big Brain werden.
Gucken, ob wir irgendwie FFmpeg zum Laufen bekommen
und dann, wie man den ganzen Krempel aufrufen kann aus JavaScript.
Wann?
Ja, irgendwann abends wieder.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nicht so spät wie heute.
Ich denke mal, also morgen arbeite ich 15.30, 16 Uhr, wahrscheinlich 15.30.
Und dann gehe ich erst mal eineinhalb, zwei, eher zwei Stunden,
wandern oder laufen.
Besser gesagt, muss mich ja bewegen.
Ich muss ja noch weiter Pepo Fett abnehmen.
Es klappt aktuell einfach zu gut, das jetzt schleifen zu lassen.
Und danach kann man eigentlich anfangen.
Also Rust WebAssembly würde ich sagen, hat gewonnen.
Es sei denn, es kommt jetzt in der letzten Sekunde noch der Vote Bot.
Okay, ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
Ich wollte das eigentlich kopieren, aber das ist verboten, wie es aussieht.
Ah ne, ich habe es noch reinkopipastet.
Ja, weil ich habe euch ja gezeigt, wie gut das Ganze läuft,
denn ich bin jetzt von 108,5 runter auf auf 97,6.
Also das sind quasi, sagen wir mal, 11 Kilo in ungefähr, also seit Ende Februar,
also seit so dreieinhalb Monaten ungefähr.
Also ich hoffe, dass also ich habe eigentlich kein richtiges Ziel.
Nur eins, und zwar ich hoffe, ich kriege irgendwann vielleicht bis Ende des Jahres was um,
vielleicht was um 90 hin, das würde mir aber schon komplett reichen erstmal.
Weil dann bin ich quasi wieder so schwer, wie seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr.
Ja, Stirnleak, ja guckt mal Leute, warte ich, warte ich ja noch drauf,
dass irgendjemand das jetzt durch den AI Algorithmus hochlädt.
Und dass ich das jetzt durch den AI Algorithmus hochlädt.
Und dass dann CSI-mäßig ranzoomt und sagt, hier Max Face liegt,
weil die Spiegelung von hier ist die Spiegelung, die in die Wand geht
und dann über die Kachel das Face aufgelöst.
Ja, also ja, man erkennt, dass ich Haare habe.
Man erkennt auch, dass ich ein Gesicht habe und eine Stirn.
Aber ich glaube, das war es im Großen und Ganzen, was man so erkennt.
Okay, dass ich rechts ein Auge habe, erkennt man auch noch, wenn man viel reininterpretiert.
viel reininterpretiert.
Aber ich glaube, davon sind die meisten Leute ausgegangen, dass ich einen Kopf habe mit Augen.
Ihr wisst ja, eine Million Subscriber, Face Reveal.
Was eh nicht passieren wird, deswegen bin ich safe.
Ich habe mich so oft schon geleakt.
Es gab sogar schon Videos, wo man mich drin gesehen hat.
Es hat bloß keiner gecheckt, dass ich das war.
Es ist auch nicht wild.
Also ganz im Ernst, mich ist es gar nicht so sehr, dass mich das großartig stören würde jetzt.
Wenn ich da irgendwo mal wirklich zu erkennen bin.
Ich will halt bloß nicht quasi für jeden offensichtlich präsent sein im Video, weil ich habe keine Lust darauf.
Ihr wisst, ich mag in der Regel keine Leute, die mir auf der Straße so über den Weg laufen und Leute, die mich ansprechen und nerven, noch weniger und ich habe einfach keinen Bock irgendwie angesprochen werden unterwegs von Leuten, die mich auf YouTube kennen.
Ich habe das gesehen, schon beim Friseur damals und das ist bei weitem nicht so krass, wie das heute ist und wir hatten damals auch bei weitem nicht so viele Subscriptions.
Wie nervig das ist und ich habe keinen Bock darauf, dass mich Leute auf der Straße erkennen und sagen, ah Max, guck mal und was auch immer, im Zweifelsfall muss ich ja noch Bilder machen mit denen oder sowas.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, da fangen wir erst gar nicht mit an.
Ja, ach stimmt, es gab ja einen neuen Official Dark Water Level Gameplay.
Okay, komm, wir sind mal nicht so, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was gerade der Chat.
Leute, ich habe ja auch sogar gesehen, ihr habt den ganzen Krempel auch noch geklippt das letzte Mal.
Ja, ja, klar, dass ich da wieder alle komplett draufstürzen habe.
Ähm, wir können uns tatsächlich, wir können uns tatsächlich mal das angucken, weil ich bin auf zweierlei Arten gespannt auf Modern Warfare 2.
Ich bin auf die erste Art gespannt, ob sich das bewahrheitet, was ich denke, nämlich, dass das eine weitere kreative Bankrotterklärung ist, was Call of Duty angeht.
Ich fand den Reboot von Modern Warfare schon bescheuert.
Also, der Erfolg gibt ihnen insofern recht, ich meine, gerade mit ihrem, dieses Warzone, könnte man fast schon Spin-Off nennen mittlerweile, wie sich das entwickelt, hat natürlich wahnsinnig viel Geld gemacht für die.
Die Bewertungen sehen schon ziemlich gut aus, ja.
Und das fanden tatsächlich auch viele Leute richtig gut.
Ich muss sagen, ich erkenne an, dass Modern Warfare für Call of Duty tatsächlich mal ein bisschen Fortschritt bedeutet hat.
Also, auch grafisch.
Die ganze Skill-Based Matchmaking-Geschichte.
Und, ja, na, da sage ich jetzt nichts zu.
Ähm, aber das Remaster oder das Re-Release oder das Reboot, muss man jetzt sagen, jetzt noch weiter.
Ich meine ernsthaft, ich war live dabei mit COD 4, mit Modern Warfare 2, mit Modern Warfare, ich habe die originale Modern Warfare Trilogie durch.
Ich war da live dabei.
Also, für mich ist es einfach nur ideenloser Aufgrund.
Das kann man jetzt über Call of Duty generell sagen, aber gerade mit Modern Warfare, finde ich, das ist halt so ein Ding, das sagt mir einfach nur, Leute, wir sind nicht mehr in der Lage, uns was anderes auszudenken und wir müssen jetzt halt maximal Kohle machen, indem wir eben die Nostalgie-Leute ansprechen und zusätzlich noch, ich weiß es nicht, es wirkt einfach so unkreativ und so gelangweilt nur noch, gerade, dass man das jetzt fortsetzt.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass...
Ich weiß nicht, dass es irgendwie jetzt übertrieben schlecht sein muss.
Ich weiß, dass das letzte Modern Warfare...
Der E-Ax ist auch da.
Ich weiß, dem E-Ax hat das wunderbar gefallen, Modern Warfare, gerade zu Release.
So, gucken wir uns mal an.
Also, zeigt mal her.
Ist das, ist das ein, ein, wie nennt man das?
Ein Reimagining der Schiffsmission, bloß auf einer Ölbohr-Plattform jetzt?
Ey, der Typ hört sich aus wie einer von Battle...
Der hört sich doch voll an wie einer von Battlefield Friends, oder?
Hört euch den Dude mal an.
Der hört sich an wie Battlefield Friends.
Oh, die sind aber ganz schön hart am Monka, am Monka-Steeren, oder?
Ist er...
Also, Captain Price hab ich jetzt, hab ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Wo hab ich eigentlich mein Monka-Steer-Emote?
Das ist weg.
Chat, wo ist, wo ist mein Monka-Steer?
Da.
Der Typ hört sich wirklich an wie einer von Battlefield Friends.
Ich mach absichtlich ein bisschen leise, weil die Call of...
Wir kennen die Call of Duty-Trailer gleich, schreien die wie verrückt rum und es explodiert Zeug.
Es wird ein Trab.
Trab.
Could be a Trab.
Warum haben die zwei keinen Helm an?
Das ist ganz einfach.
Das ist wie in einem Film.
Das soll cool aussehen, dass man die Gesichter der Charakter sieht.
Niemand würde in sowas ohne Helm gehen.
Soll...
Soll das Saub sein?
Wegen dem Haarschnitt?
Nee, oder?
Ist das Saub?
Soll das Saub sein?
Ich mein, vom Haarschnitt her wird's passen.
Sag mal.
Wollen die uns...
Ganz ernsthaft, da sehen die nicht.
Das ist Saub.
Das ist wirklich Saub.
Habt ihr das grad gehört?
Ich muss...
Ich bin da wirklich sehr zwiegespalten.
Auf der einen Seite finde ich das, als jemand, der Call of Duty 4 gut fand,
und ich hab auch gerne MW2 gesuchtet, cool, dass Saub wieder am Start ist.
Aber es ist, und das muss man einfach trotz diesem Wiedererkennungswert sagen,
es ist einfach komplette kreative Bankrotterklärung.
Jetzt nochmal die ganze Geschichte mit Saub.
Und Pryce, ich mein ernsthaft.
Wir haben's doch schon komplett durch.
Da fühlst du dich gar nicht so übel aus.
Ist das vielleicht auf Xbox?
Nö.
Doch, kann's in Ordnung aus.
Ja, wir machen mal ein bisschen höher.
Okay, das ist nur noch 15 Call of Duty-Kost aktuell.
Ich mein, seriously, niemand spielt das so.
Man sprintet da durch.
Wie sie da immer rumschleichen.
Stelzmodus aktiviert.
Gehen wir zum Hauptdeck.
Was ist ihr Status?
Wir fahren das Schiff mit Shadow 3 jetzt.
Roger das.
Immer schön den Boden abamen, genau.
Eigentlich, Leute, ernsthaft, eigentlich hätten wir schon direkt erraten können,
dass dieser Typ jetzt stirbt, weil es der einzige Charakter ist mit Helm auf.
Das ist quasi austauschbarer Statist.
Das Spiel sieht nicht besser aus als MW2 2019.
Nee, das hätte ich jetzt aber auch nicht erwartet.
Das wird doch wie bei Call of Duty immer.
So sein jetzt der letzte große Sprung für Call of Duty war mit Modern Warfare 2019,
wo man sich auch mal wirklich was am Unterbau getan hat.
Das wird jetzt für die nächsten zehn Jahre bis zum nächsten Modern Warfare Reboot wird das so bleiben.
Modern Warfare 1 hat damals quasi die Grafik ziemlich modernisiert.
Das war damals auf quasi.
Von der Grafik her bei den Leuten im Kopf nicht viel schlechter als Crysis, was blödsinnig ist, aber viele Leute, die sich nicht mehr daran interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren, die sich nicht mehr interessieren.
Viele Leute haben damals beides als super krass toll angesehen.
Und jetzt hat es halt bis zum Modern Warfare Reboot gebraucht, bis das Spiel wieder ordentlich aussieht.
Und jetzt brauchen wir wahrscheinlich das nächste Modern Warfare Reboot.
Also so ungefähr 2030.
Dann, dann wird die Grafik wieder aktualisiert.
Also acht Jahre kann man jetzt schon noch mit der alten Grafik von 2019 leben.
Ich meine, Call of Duty hat davor auch zehn Jahre mit der Grafik von Modern Warfare 4 von Call of Duty 4 gelebt.
Warum?
Warum haben die eigentlich, das war eine bescheuerte Frage, warum haben die eigentlich die Stun-Granate, beziehungsweise das Flashbang, so geworfen und so geguckt, dass sie es selbst abbekommen haben?
Ich meine, ist das nicht, ist das nicht irgendwie ziemlich pepega?
Oder?
Also, meinen ja nur.
Aber um so Sachen muss man sich ja bei bestem Willen keine Gedanken machen.
Es sieht sehr nach ziemlich Standard Call of Duty Cost aus.
Also.
Das könnte quasi auch exakt so im originalen Modern Warfare gewesen sein.
Es sieht ein bisschen besser aus.
Okay, ich, ich predict, ich predikte mal was, was jetzt noch passiert.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich recht habe.
Ich predikte, gleich kommt ein Chopper und dann wird der Chopper mit dem RPG abgeschossen.
Wo auch immer der Heli herkommt.
Also vom Aufbau her soll das, glaube ich, wirklich absichtlich ein bisschen an das Schiffslevel erinnern aus Call of Duty 4.
hier. Oh, damit
richtig rein mit Flieger.
Also, ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig,
dass diese Station
am Ende in die Luft fliegt und untergeht
oder man gerade rechtzeitig abgeholt
wird, wenn es explodiert oder so. Das ist das
klar. Aber ich predikte immer noch, dass
gleich ein Chopper kommt, der abgeschossen werden muss.
Ach ja, ja.
Die rote Container, selbstverständlich.
Was sonst?
Klassiker.
Ihr habt bestimmt
bei euch auch im Flur rote
Container rumstehen, die in die Luft fliegen, wenn man drauf
schießt. Wer hat es nicht? Grinch, wer es nicht
hat. Der weiß überhaupt
nicht, ob clear ist.
Wisst ihr, was mich das ein bisschen erinnert?
Kennt noch jemand diese Spec Ops Mission
aus Modern Warfare 2 mit der
mit dieser Insel?
Wo man mit dieser Ölplattform
oder was das war? Das könnte
sogar eine der letzten Missionen gewesen sein.
Die war gar nicht so leicht.
Wo dann irgendwie noch zig Juggernauts
gekommen sind und sowas. Es gab so eine Spec Ops Mission
in MW2 für
auf so einer Insel.
Also wenn die jetzt wieder
eine Nuke finden, wie in MW4, äh
wie in COD4, also
ich hoffe
nicht. Nichts, es wäre
wirklich exakt wieder der gleiche Krempel.
Okay, es ist
typisches, typisches Call of Duty
Kram.
Okay, die übliche bisschen Knockout.
Jetzt kommt gleich Price um die Ecke und hilft
einem hoch oder sowas.
Oh nein, man kann diesmal selbst aufstehen.
Ach, das ist ja gar nicht Price.
Ja, das ist jetzt
Ich sag euch,
das ist absichtlich so gemacht, dass die
Leute sich erinnert fühlen an die Schiffsmissionen
von Call of Duty 4.
Das wird bestimmt auch eine
Multiplayer Map.
Sag mal, was muss man eigentlich machen,
damit man Trailer, ähm
Vorspieler werden darf?
Naja, das ist Original MW1
hier. Also nicht, nicht Original, aber es
ist absichtlich quasi gemacht
in dieser
in der gleichen Art und Weise.
Network hieß die Map, ja genau.
Ah ja, Bina, ah ja, Bina.
Tango Sucker.
Da fehlen, da fehlen
die, die, die realistischen
Sounds, ja. Die realistischen
Sprüche.
Für Pega-Aim braucht man, ja.
War wie?
Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das jetzt auf der einen Seite
Ne, eigentlich finde ich es nicht cool.
Das ist, das ist, das ist nicht nur
dran orientiert.
Ich meine, das ist
mehr oder weniger das Level aus
Modern Warfare 1.
Aus Modern Warfare 1.
Dem Nicht-Reboot, dem Original.
Es kam normalerweise jetzt der
Heli. Normalerweise kam jetzt der Heli.
Aber die sind ja nicht mit dem Heli gelandet.
Ah, Door-Breach, Door-Breach.
Nein.
Ich pre-ordere
definitiv nicht now.
Tja.
Es sieht aus, als
hat man Call of Duty 4 nochmal
re-verwurstet.
Das könnte allerdings, witzigerweise,
auch wenn ich jetzt ein paar Mal gesagt habe, ich finde,
das kreiert von der Kreativität komplett
für die Tonne, aber es könnte tatsächlich dazu führen,
dass ich das spiele. Einfach, weil ich wissen will,
was sie draus gemacht haben.
Hat Dizzy erfolgreich gebaidet.
Sie müssen nur Content bringen
ohne cringe Voice Lines.
Die müssten überhaupt
Content bringen, dann sind sie schon besser als
Battlefield 2042.
Was hältst du von Linus Tech-Tipps?
Guck ich so gut wie nicht.
Ich geb ab und zu mal die ein oder anderen
ganz nicen Videos, aber
also, ich seh für mich jetzt da nicht den Grund,
warum ich mir das öfters angucken sollte.
Also, ist irgendwie was dabei, wo ich sagen würde,
oh, da hab ich jetzt was gelernt oder hab ich da was gesehen,
das war mir so noch nicht klar oder irgendwie,
oh, das war, es ist selten.
Eins muss man sagen, also, ja, doch eine Sache
halte ich von Linus Tech-Tipps, er ist der Meister
der Abo-Sellout, äh, nicht der Abo-Sellout,
der Shop-Sellout-Überleitung.
Also, das können die wirklich gut.
Die machen ja mittlerweile dreimal Sellout in so einem Video.
Die machen entweder, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt,
entweder Sponsor-Sellout am Anfang, Sponsor-Sellout am Ende,
ähm, eigener Shop, sonst was noch, Sellout,
also, das haben die wirklich wahnsinnig drauf.
Den Sellout haben die perfektioniert.
Zumal, die haben die ja schon mal remastert und neu verkauft.
Ich bin mal gespannt, vielleicht, ich mein,
was man ja auch machen könnte, ist,
man könnte, also, ich sag jetzt mal was,
ich geh nicht davon aus, dass sie's machen,
aber man könnte die Leute auch richtig krass tübaiten.
Überlegt euch mal, erste Mission,
du bist mit Soap auf dem Schiff und du denkst dir so,
fuck, ich weiß, was kommt und dann stirbt Soap einfach.
So instant, durch irgendwie so nen random NPC.
Und es passiert was ganz anderes, als man erwartet hätte.
Oder was auch immer, sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das machen werden.
Ja, das, das quasi alternate reality, irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaub's aber nicht.
Naja, warum nicht?
Es muss ja nicht nur durch nen random NPC sein,
es könnte ja tatsächlich auch durch den Bösewicht sein und am Ende dann, was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Ich mein, sie können ja nicht wirklich Call of Duty 4 nochmal neu,
wobei, was sag ich, sie können nicht wirklich, also,
doch, das können sie und das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch.
Sie werden wahrscheinlich Call of Duty 4 bringen mit leichter Abwandlung.
Und Nostalgie abgreifen, ja.
Naja.
Mal gucken.
Bin gespannt, wann, äh, habt ihr gesehen, wann Release Date war?
Ich will nicht meine Waage gucken.
Äh, wann war denn nochmal...
What the fuck?
Okay, ich krieg's nicht mehr geöffnet.
Warum?
Na, was ist denn hier los?
Äh, ähm...
Wann war nochmal Release Date?
Sekunde.
Achso, ne.
Hm.
Ich, ich, ich finde neulich mal mehr, was wir gerade geguckt haben, okay.
Ich könnte jetzt in die History gucken, aber scheiß drauf.
Ähm, wann ist denn Release Date?
Bestimmt November, wie immer wahrscheinlich, oder?
Modern Warfare 2 Release Date.
Er kommt wahrscheinlich bei Google, ja, 2009.
Release steht fest, okay.
Okto-, ach, Oktober sind wir heute ein bisschen früher.
28. Oktober.
Ist ja nicht so, dass sie Angst vor der Battlefield-Konkurrenz haben müssten.
Da ist ja nicht viel zu holen.
Ich werde morgen in ein paar Runden Zero Hour spielen.
Vielleicht im Stream, mal gucken.
Und um festzustellen, dass es halt nichts gibt, im Endeffekt.
Die haben bestimmt wieder alte Reload-Animationen und sowas auch importiert.
Okay, wollen wir uns...
Komm, wir lassen uns noch ne Runde von LevelCapture baden.
Battlefield 2042 ist in Abandoned Ship mode.
Sagt wer? Tom Henderson oder wer?
Ganz im Ernst, selbst wenn das...
Also, mich würde es wundern, wenn das nicht so wäre.
Ich dachte schon die ganze Zeit, dass die da eigentlich nichts machen.
Dass die da noch ein paar Leute sitzen haben, die das absolut Mindeste liefern.
Ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen, das ist gut.
Das muss ich jetzt auch anklicken für die, für die, für die View-Time, ja.
Lass es im Hintergrund mal laufen.
Ähm, die das absolut Mindeste...
Wie findet ihr das Thumbnail?
Ich finde, es ist eigentlich ganz gut gelungen.
Das sieht so aus, als möchte man es anklicken.
Ja.
Und, ähm...
Das sieht so aus, als möchte man es anklicken.
Ähm, ja.
Das da, wie gesagt, dass da einfach noch ein paar Hansel sitzen, ein paar Dice, die das absolut Mindeste liefern, was sein muss.
Und dann wird es eingestellt.
Ja, gucken wir uns...
Komm, wir lassen uns doch mal eine Runde Level Cap.
G-Baden.
Battlefield 2042's future sounds more uncertain than ever.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare...
Ach.
Wirklich?
Gameplay was revealed.
Diablo Immortal players are outraged and much more...
Outraged ist ja heutzutage...
Schon Standard.
Also, sag mir mal, irgendwann gab es irgendwie einen Tag in den letzten 10 Jahren über, wo nicht irgendwas besonders outrage...
Outraging war?
Egal was es war, es war jeden Tag irgendwas.
Super krasser Outrage.
On today in gaming.
Battlefield 2042 Season 1 was revealed.
War ganz einfach abgesehen.
Über Diablo Immortal kann man tatsächlich outraged sein.
Yesterday and the reaction to all the info has been, well, mixed.
Fans are excited about the new content, but many say it's not.
But many say it's too little too late.
The new content goes live tomorrow, adding one specialist, two new guns, a new gadget, two
new stealth helicopters and a new...
Ist das eigentlich jetzt schon live, Zero Hour?
Ja, gell?
Ach, das ist auch von gestern.
Map.
Based on my experience with the content so far, it does seem considerably better than
most of the stuff that's already...
Das ist auch keine Kunst.
And if you want a full breakdown of that info and my impressions, check out yesterday's
video.
During a Q&A session at the end of the preview, DICE's comments also failed to give fans confidence
in the game's future.
They committed to supporting 2042 with four seasons of content, and they said they want
to keep this game going to make it the best it can be, and they don't have an end date
for this particular game.
However, today, industry insider Jeff Grubb claimed that 2042 is being worked on by a
content crew whose priority is fulfilling their year-one...
Ach, nein!
Ich find das geil, wie du jetzt irgendwelche krassen Leaker brauchst, um so das komplett
obvious Zeug...
Dass die Leute auf diese Idee überhaupt erst kommen, ja?
Wie gesagt, ich sag das schon mehr oder weniger seit dem Release, was passieren wird.
Es ist einfach nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie die krassen prophetischen Voraussehungskünste
hätte oder so.
Aber es ist doch klar, es ist doch offensichtlich, es würde eher wundern, wenn das anders gewesen
wäre.
Und, ja, da müssen jetzt irgendwelche tollen Insider kommen, die das dann sagen...
Ach übrigens, Leute!
Das ist so und so!
Ich so, was?
Wirklich?
Na, da hätten wir jetzt ja gar nicht mit rechnen können.
Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass Diablo Immortal im App-Store mit 4,6 bewertet ist?
Weiß ich nicht, aber entweder kriegst du kostenloses Gear für eine Bewertung.
Das ist ja auch gängige Praxis bei Mobile Games.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das mittlerweile, ähm...
noch erlaubt ist.
Oder es ist halt genau die richtige Zielgruppe dafür, nämlich Mobile Gamer.
Und ich habe heute bei Trimax, ich gucke normalerweise nie Trimax, aber es wurde mir empfohlen, Diablo
Immortal.
Ich habe irgendein Video bei Trimax geguckt, kurz irgendwas, wir cashen richtig rein in
Diablo Immortal.
Und die Leute haben das Game mega abgefeiert in den Kommentaren.
Und auch mit so Dingern wie, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum sich hier alle aufregen über
Pay2Win.
Du musst doch überhaupt nichts ausgeben.
Und haha!
Ich habe einen riesen Spaß mit diesem Game.
So viel Spaß hatte ich schon lange mit keinem Spiel mehr.
Also, vielleicht trifft es auch gerade den Nerv von vielen.
Ich glaube, dass ihr das schaffen könnt.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Blizzard wird garantiert das komplette, wobei Blizzard, es ist ja im Prinzip Blizzard plus
ein China-Chinesen-Hersteller.
Natürlich, Blizzard wird das ganz bestimmt überarbeiten und es zu einem viel besseren
Game ohne Pay2Win machen.
Kappa!
Ganz sicherlich.
...works on the next game.
He says it's basically in a better game.
Basically in abandoned shipments.
Wir haben den Modern Warfare 2 Trailer gerade geguckt, ja.
EA have already put the next Battlefield game into pre-production.
Das ist ja auch nichts neues.
Any franchise's core development group is leading work on it.
Ja, aber sagen wir mal so, das ist ja normal.
Also, du hast bei größeren Spielen, vor allem die halt auch in einem strafferen Release-Zyklus
erscheinen, muss jetzt nicht gleich so krass wie Call of Duty sein, wenn das eine Game
fertig ist, selbstverständlich wird sich dann um das neue Game gekümmert.
Ja, was denn sonst?
Das entwickelt sich nicht von alleine.
Wobei, man könnte vielleicht argumentieren, wenn irgendeine advancede AI Battlefield entwickelt
hätte, aus Teilen der alten Battlefields, dann wäre es besser geworden als Battlefield
2042, aber noch haben die da ein eigenes Entwicklerteam für und selbstverständlich
arbeiten die an einem neuen Game, wenn das aktuelle Game fertig ist.
Was nicht zwangsläufig heißt, dass das alte komplett auf Sparflamme laufen muss, ja.
Du kannst ja durchaus Leute der Sache zuteilen oder auch andere Leute hinsetzen.
Du brauchst ja dann nicht unbedingt jetzt deine five-headigsten Frostbite-Entwickler
für das alte Game, ja.
Aber ansonsten wundert das überhaupt nicht.
Was ist das überhaupt für eine Auflösung da im Hintergrund?
Das war ja...
Ach, jetzt ist die Auflösung auf einmal gut.
Na dann.
Die Worte krechten beim Start.
Geht ja gut los.
Ah nein, jetzt musste ich gewonnen werden, vor allem ist die Auflösung hier in der
Außenwindung nicht ف solBlendin.
Was liegt eighthand accurate to?
Ihr habt euch selbst Handschellen angelegt Dice, es war eure freie Wahl.
Ihr habt das Game designt, es ist jetzt nicht, es ist doch nicht so als hätten die Spieler
gesagt, DICE ihr müsst 128 Spieler machen, sonst gibts haue.
Dice hat gesagt, wir machen 128 Spieler, und das ist das geilsten Spiel der ganzen Sonne.
So, jetzt ist einfach nichts geklappt.
Und das ist das geilste seitgeschnitten Brot. Und alle haben gesagt, bin mir nicht so sicher, ob 128 Spieler eine gute Idee ist. Und jetzt tun sie es uns nach dem Wort. Wir haben uns uns ansteckelt von 128. Also ernsthaft jetzt.
Ja, und wir wissen natürlich auch, das was DICE sagt, da ist ja Verlass drauf.
Die Devs haben auch erklärt, dass zukünftige Mappen mit Lernlern von den Launch-Mappen entwickelt werden.
Die Mappe von Season 1...
Battlefield 2042!
...wurde angeblich entwickelt mit Lessons Learned.
Ein Law-Flatter an die Community ist Portal, Leute.
Oh Mann, dieses Geschwätze. Ich drehe irgendwann echt noch am Rad.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht mehr anhören.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist die neue Map wirklich gut, ja?
Die Option müssen wir uns mal offen halten.
Aber selbst wenn die neue Map wirklich gut ist,
das Spiel hat kein Content.
Dann hast du eine neue Map.
Okay, die Map spiele ich vielleicht mal 2, 3, wenn es hochkommt, eine Woche.
Immer mal wieder und dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr, weil immer die gleiche Map den ganzen Tag.
Oder was heißt den ganzen Tag? Den ganzen Spielzeit will ja auch keiner machen.
Wo ist denn eigentlich mal ordentlich neuer Content für Portal?
Man könnte so viele Sachen dort importieren aus alten Battlefields, aber man will nicht.
Und das ist das, was ich die ganze Zeit sage.
Man hat das Spiel mehr oder weniger seit diesem verschissenen Release.
Und man weiß, dass ich das nicht mehr eröffne.
Die sind ja auch nicht blöd dort.
Die haben ja auch Leute, die das analysieren.
Hat man das komplett auf Sparflamme laufen.
Man liefert das Mindeste, was man muss, damit man nicht verklagt wird und fertig.
Ja, ja.
Ah, guck mal.
Ghost ist auch am Start.
Und Ghost hat diesmal ernsthaft ne Maske auf, anstatt nen Lappen überm Gesicht, oder wie?
Warum sollte einer eine Maske aufziehen?
Der originale Ghost hatte nen Lappen überm Gesicht.
Das ist das, was man auch erwartet.
würde, wenn man überhaupt was über dem Gesicht hat. Aber da zieht doch keiner ne Maske auf!
Das ist Standard-Zeug.
Ja, gut, das machen sie wahrscheinlich, hauptsächlich, dass sie sich die Arbeit nicht machen müssen, das zu supporten.
Und wahrscheinlich, dass die Leute auch noch ein bisschen mehr reinkashen.
Sie können halt das alte Modern Warfare da nicht...
Also, das alte Modern Warfare.
Das alte Warzone nicht einfach abschalten, weil die Leute dann direkt rumschreien würden, so nach dem Motto,
Alter, ich hab hier quasi hunderttausende Sachen unlockt und ihr schaltet das jetzt einfach ab.
Aber realistisch betrachtet, werden die Leute selbstverständlich das Neue spielen.
Vielleicht steige ich auch mal ein, zumindest am Anfang, wenn Warzone neu ist.
Ich fand's gar nicht so schlecht, muss ich sagen.
Also, jetzt so rückblickend, es war gar nicht schlecht.
Es war vor allem cool,
wenn man das im...
Wenn man das im Squad gespielt hat.
Ich bin nie so hundertprozentig warm geworden, dass ich jetzt 24-7 grinden wollte.
Aber vielleicht gebe ich mir das dann auch ein paar Wochen, wenn's raus ist.
Warzone 2 ist eine saubere Liste, die keinen Erfolg oder Geld auf Warzone 1 reflektieren wird.
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie investiert die Spieler sind...
Ja, da hast du recht.
Das denke ich auch.
Jetzt, wo du's sagst.
Man möchte das doch noch mehr entkoppeln.
Price hat wieder so diese Pausbäckchen, die er schon im ersten Modern Warfare hatte.
Der Typ, der Schauspieler, hatte ihn echt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum Price so aussieht.
Keine Ahnung, was die mit diesem Model gemacht haben.
... Cosmetics and how incredibly extensive its options are, plus its inclusion of three entire games worth of weapons,
that's a massive blow to fans of the Battle Royale.
Players have gotten used to Warzone offering a ton of content from multiple games all in one place.
Starting from scratch with nothing to show for your past commitment
is probably a tough pill to swallow for many players.
Warzone 2 will probably launch sometime after Modern Warfare 2's release in October 28th
and likely before the end of the year.
The recently released, mobile-focused Diablo Immortals microtransactions are drawing intense scrutiny from players.
In a nutshell, players are able to buy a pass that boosts their loot drops and they can also pay for gear upgrades.
Paying for these things massively shortcuts your progress in the game, since the free-to-play progression...
Da muss man sich angucken. Da habe ich mich ja nur ausführlich genug drüber ausgelassen heute.
... progression has time limits and may be more cosmetic-oriented.
Juckt mich auch nicht.
Juckt mich auch nicht und vor allem juckt es auch keinen mehr, der Halo Infinite spielt.
Und juckt mich auch nicht.
Okay, fertig. Level cap jebaited.
Bisschen Viewtime auf meinen eigenen Videos noch nebenbei.
So muss das sein.
Ah ja, mal schauen.
Es wär cool.
Es wär tatsächlich cool, wenn Modern Warfare 2 was taugt.
Wenn es was ist, was man auch spielen kann oder Bock drauf hat zu spielen.
Ich fürchte halt, das normale Multiplayer wird wieder unspielbar.
Es sei denn, man steht halt auf immer 50-50, also immer halt auf...
Dank Skill-Based Matchmaking immer auf quasi ähnlich viele Kills wie Death.
Ich denke, die werden Skill-Based Matchmaking wieder auf 500% drehen in MW2.
Und es wird wieder rumgecampt as fuck.
Wird doch Zeit, dass ich den SCUF Controller mal order.
Aber ich spiel ja gar nicht mit Controller.
Naja, mal abwarten.
Warum ist YouTube eigentlich der Meinung, ich möchte unbedingt einen Stream von Tekken sehen?
Das läuft immer noch.
Ich guck mir morgen eine Zusammenfassung an.
Ich kann mir diese ganze Geschichte mit new, amazing, noch nie dagewesene Experience nicht mehr geben.
Alles ist super thrilled und super neu und super innovativ und einfach das Beste aller Zeiten.
Und am Ende denkst du dir so, ja und was war das jetzt?
Ich guck mir irgendeine Zusammenfassung an.
Guck mal hier, hier lernen wir, wie man den Ausweis richtig schwärzt.
Scheinen voll viele Leute zu interessieren.
Ich hab auch mal meinen Ausweis geschwärzt.
Und zwar, wo ich mit G2A einen Vertrag gemacht hab über Promotion.
Die haben gemeint, sie wollen unbedingt meinen Ausweis haben, weil das irgendwie dann mehr credible ist oder was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Hab ich gesagt, ihr kriegt aber meinen Ausweis nicht.
Ich mein, würdet, seriously, würdet ihr G2A euren Ausweis schicken?
Und, ähm, die haben gesagt, ja, aber das geht sonst nicht anders.
Ich schick euch aber nicht meinen Ausweis.
Und irgendwann hab ich gesagt, weißt du was, doch, doch.
Ich schick dir den Ausweis.
Aber ich werde alles schwärzen außer meinen Namen.
Das war auch okay.
Haben sie genommen.
Hast du das Statement von EA gesehen?
Guck mal her.
Um was, um was geht's?
Okay.
I said that Battlefield is down to a skeleton crew that is trying to meet its DLC.
Exakt das, exakt das, was ich seit Release sage, ja.
EA has reached out to say this is untrue.
Okay.
Mal gucken, wie sie das jetzt, äh, obfuscaten und verschleiern wollen.
Also, this is untrue.
Also.
Es ist wirklich ein beachtliches Team.
Über mehrere Studios, ähm, fokussiert.
Um, was, Moment.
Äh, um Battlefield 2042 zu verbessern und weiterzuentwickeln.
Für die Spieler natürlich, ganz, ganz klar.
Okay, und viele auch aus dem DICE-Kernteam.
Hm.
Sie sind committed zu Battlefield 2042.
Okay, und das ist im Prinzip, gilt das, was im Team erlaubt wird.
Schwachsinn.
Ich mein, das kannst du, das, du kannst dieses Statement sogar rausnehmen.
Du kannst dieses Statement sogar raushauen, ohne wirklich zu lügen.
Ich mein, das fängt ja damit schon an.
Significant Team.
Das, wer weiß, was damit gemeint ist.
Was ist das?
Eins, zwei, fünf, zehn, zwanzig.
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß, man weiß es nicht, ja.
Also, das ist bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Du kannst davon ausgehen.
Ich mein, eigentlich können die nur verlieren.
Überlegt euch doch mal.
Entweder, es ist so, wie er gesagt hat, was ich ja auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile sage,
dass das einfach nur mit einem Minimal-Team weiterbetrieben wird und das Mindeste geliefert wird, was man, was man liefern muss.
Oder aber, die andere Möglichkeit wäre, sie sind schlicht und ergreifend unfähig.
Weil, stellt euch mal vor, sie hätten wirklich ein richtig echtes Significant Team mit vielen Leuten von DICE dran.
Warum brauchen die denn dann acht Monate für drei neue Boxen auf Kaleidoskop zu stellen?
Warum braucht man mit einem richtig Significant Team von Leuten, die Ahnung haben von Battlefield, ewig, acht Monate, um irgendwas zu machen in diesem Spiel?
Also, es gibt aktuell die Auswahl zwischen sie lügen oder sie sagen die Wahrheit und sind unfähig.
Ich weiß nicht, was davon besser ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich lügen sie.
Das würde mich jetzt am wenigsten wundern.
Moin, Cielle.
Du Geringverdiener.
Ron Biele...
Okay, Leute, ich hab echt...
Ich hab echt so keine Ahnung von irgendwelchen angeblich Celebrity Leuten, die man kennen soll.
Wer zum Teufel ist Ron Bielecki?
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, wer das ist.
Ist das einer von irgendeiner Soap oder so?
Ah, ne.
Ich hab gehört, er wäre vielleicht auch im Fernsehen.
Soap247 mit InScope.
Ja, das ist ja so...
Woher kennt man den denn?
Das ist ein Fitness-YouTuber.
Ah.
Okay, gute Zusammenfassung.
Es war mal ein Fitness-YouTuber, jetzt läuft er sich zu.
Kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber wenn ich das Bild hier sehe, scheint da was dran zu sein.
The fuck?
Von dem ist der Tornado.
Welcher Tornado?
Ich bin echt nicht up-to-date, was YouTube Deutschland angeht.
Und ich muss sagen, ich find's gut.
Ich hab mich noch nie für YouTube Deutschland großartig interessiert.
Und umso mehr ich mitbekomme von YouTube Deutschland, umso froher bin ich, dass ich mich nicht für YouTube Deutschland interessier.
Oder generell für YouTube Drama oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das letzte... Wisst ihr, was das letzte YouTube Drama war, wo ich aktiv teilgenommen habe und mich dafür interessiert hab?
Das war noch... Soll EloTrix King of Web werden?
Erinnert ihr euch noch?
Wo überall auf YouTube rumgespammt wurde, unterstützt jetzt King of Web und sowas?
Wo ich ein Video gemacht hab, Leute, jetzt hört mal auf zu spammen.
Das ist das letzte, woran ich mich erinnere und das ist auch schon...
Keine Ahnung...
Elf Jahre her.
Das ist quasi YouTube RTL.
Ja, Chat, da habt ihr recht. So was in der Richtung ist es.
So, jetzt hab ich mein eigenes Video genug laufen lassen.
Pog.
Da waren ja wieder Kommentare dabei.
Da musste ich auch nur mit dem Kopf schütteln.
Wie sich die Leute das Spiel wieder schön riechen.
Wie sich die Leute das Spiel wieder schön reden.
Er hat nicht unrecht.
Zumindest mit dem einen Punkt.
Er sagt halt leider nichts zu dem, was ich gesagt hab.
Ich mein...
Hätte er jetzt gesagt, Max, du hast nicht recht, weil so und so.
Dann hätte man ja sagen können, okay, seh ich ein.
Aber hat er nicht.
Aber da sind teilweise Kommentare dabei.
Da greifst du dir echt an den Kopf.
Naja...
Ich glaube, YouTube hat auch festgestellt, dass ich richtig krasser Boomer bin.
Ich mein, warum sonst?
Ich mein, warum sonst werden mir so Sachen wie Verstehen Sie Spaß empfohlen?
Oh Leute, ich bin so im Arsch.
Zum Glück ist morgen Wochenende.
Wisst ihr, ich hab gar...
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr daran reindenken, wie ich es mal geschafft habe,
nicht nur fünf Tage die Woche zu arbeiten, sondern jeden Tag zu pendeln mit dem Zug nach Frankfurt.
Und nicht nur das, sogar teilweise mit dem Bus zum Bahnhof fahren noch vorher und dann zu pendeln.
Wie hab ich das überhaupt überlebt?
Also...
Wie bin ich 37 geworden?
Wie hab ich das geistig verkraftet?
Keine Ahnung.
Du verlierst nicht nur einfach saumäßig viel Zeit.
Du bist auch quasi den kompletten Tag und du bist quasi 80% deines Lebens einfach nur todmüde.
Wenn du das sowas machst.
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass man sowas als normal empfindet.
Aber ich hab's damals als normal empfunden.
Dachte mir, das ist halt so.
Nee, beim JP-Morgenlauf bin ich nicht gewesen.
Konnte man da nicht letztes Jahr sogar von zu Hause mit einem Laufband mitmachen?
Da war doch was.
Als Corona war und das abgesagt wurde.
Lohnt sich das Software-Engineer im Homeoffice?
Ja, das haben wir gesehen.
Kennen wir.
Haben wir schon geguckt.
Warum du kein Programmierer werden solltest.
Okay.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Warum sollte ich kein Programmierer werden?
Okay, ich kann euch sagen, warum man kein C++-Programmierer werden sollte.
Da gibt's jede Menge gute Gründe.
Aber so allgemein.
Sekunde.
Also, warum?
Warum?
Äh.
Ah.
Hier.
Enojibate?
Meinst du?
Ja, wir skippen mal kurz drüber.
Erster Nachteil.
Nachteil.
Management in Europa.
Okay, da kannst du ja sein, dass ich dem zustimme.
Richtig.
Ich...
Okay.
Moment.
Ist...
Ist das hier der einzige Teil, wo es um die Überschrift geht?
Dann hat das YouTube-Game durchgespielt.
So musst du es machen.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Warum?
Heute lassen wir mal diese ganze Glanz und Glorie am Programmierer-Dasein weg und reden
über die Nachteile.
Ich meine, immer mehr Leute wollen ja Programmierer werden.
Und es ist ja auch kein Wunder.
Ich meine, man hat gute Bezahlung, gute Arbeitszeiten.
Man kann sich echt kreativ ausleben.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wollen immer mehr Leute Programmierer werden?
Ist das so?
Also es wollen, glaube ich, immer mehr Leute Streamer werden und sowas.
Aber immer mehr Leute Programmierer werden wollen...
Gut, nachdem immer mehr Leute wahrscheinlich in die IT wollen, wollen unterm Strich auch
immer mehr Leute Programmierer werden.
Das wird schon stimmen.
Alles toll.
Aber es gibt halt auch, wie bei jedem anderen Job, Nachteile am Programmierer-Dasein.
Und darüber möchte ich heute mit dir reden.
Weil manche...
Ja, vor allem, wenn man C++-Programmierer ist.
Wie gesagt...
Die Nachteile dieser Nachteile sind halt auch ziemlich eklig.
Und genau, wenn du jetzt Programmierer werden willst und gerade am Anfang stehst, dann ist
es halt wichtig, dass du deine Entscheidung nicht nur basierend auf den Vorteilen triffst,
sondern natürlich auch basierend auf den Nachteilen.
Da ist was dran.
Weil du dich jetzt fragst, wer ich bin.
Mein Name ist Yunus Ergin und ich programmiere inzwischen seit 15 Jahren.
Ich war Tech-Lead in einem deutschen Start-up und habe da natürlich dann auch gearbeitet.
Und deswegen weiß ich, dass der Job zwar natürlich ziemlich geil ist, aber halt auch den ein
oder anderen Nachteil hat.
Und darüber reden wir heute.
Kommen wir gleich zum ersten Nachteil.
Programmieren kann richtig stressig sein.
Was meine ich damit?
Das ist wahr.
Also als Programmierer ist es ganz normal, dass du geduldig sein musst, dass du Disziplin
brauchst und dass du auch Durchhaltevermögen brauchst.
Das heißt, ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag sieht zum Beispiel...
Ach, das ist aber Code Review.
Nee, bei mir sieht Code Review immer anders aus.
Max, ich habe ein Pull-Request aufgemacht.
Nimm mal an.
So ungefähr läuft das bei uns.
Es sieht so aus, dass du in die Firma gehst.
Du holst dir da ganz gemütlich deinen ersten Kaffee.
Ich trinke keinen Kaffee, aber bei den meisten ist es wahrscheinlich so.
Oh nein!
Gute Kopfhörer.
Einen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich den habe, aber einen von dieser Serie habe ich auch gekauft
damals wegen dem Noise-Canceling.
Ich muss sagen, es hat sich wirklich gelohnt.
Gerade wenn man Bahn fährt oder wenn man im Büro sitzt und die Leute labern, finde
ich das wirklich angenehm, sich einfach einen Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer aufzusetzen.
Und man hat seine Ruhe.
Man kann den Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer auch aufziehen, ohne Musik anzumachen.
Ist dann auch ganz gut.
Und er hat ein gutes Notebook mit dem IBM-Nippel.
Ja, das heißt, ein Computerfehler, irgendein Fehler an deinem Programm.
Du reparierst das schnell in fünf Minuten.
Oh, Angular, Monka.
Und denkst, super.
Es ist gerade mal 10 Uhr morgens und ich habe schon das größte Problem des Tages gefixt.
Und dann funktioniert es.
Und dann funktioniert es nicht.
Und 45 Minuten später crasht das gesamte System.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, der ganze Server ist plötzlich down.
Okay, also wenn der Server von der Web-Anwendung crasht, dann würde ich mir Gedanken machen.
Aber ich gette den Point.
Und dann gibt es halt so manche Tage, da denkst du, ach, gar kein Problem.
Ich löse jetzt einfach schnell diese Probleme.
Das ist jetzt das Problem A, B, C habe ich hier jetzt beispielsweise verursacht.
Und du nimmst jetzt einfach 10 Minuten super konzentriert und löst das.
Aber dann gibt es halt auch diese anderen Tage.
Und dann, wisst ihr, was dann passiert?
Wisst ihr, was in diesem Moment passiert, wenn du dir das hier denkst?
Du nimmst jetzt einfach 10 Minuten super konzentriert und löst das.
Aber dann gibt es halt auch diese anderen Tage.
Und an diesen anderen Tagen ist es so, dass du einfach da versichert vorsitzt und denkst, oh nein, ich habe alles kaputt gemacht.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht einfach machen.
Ungefähr so läuft das dann, wenn du dich 10 Minuten konzentrieren willst.
Funktionieren.
Zusätzlich ist es häufig noch so, dass du halt dich in Software-Projekte in einer Firma reinarbeitest.
In einer Firma reinarbeiten musst, die nicht von dir sind.
Das heißt, du musst halt fremden Code verstehen.
Und manchmal hast du es sogar so, dass die Person, die den Code geschrieben hat, gar nicht mehr in der Firma arbeitet.
Oh ja, das haben wir auch öfters.
Das haben wir auch öfters.
Irgendjemand hat bei uns ein Ticket aufgemacht.
Wir sollen bitte aus irgendeinem alten Mainframe, was war das?
Irgendein, ich weiß gar nicht, wie dieser Krempel heißt.
Irgendwelche IBM Mainframe Script.
Die auf irgendeinem, frag mich nicht, Job-Controller liegen.
Ob wir da nicht ein paar Zeilen ändern können drinnen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich fasse das Ding nicht an.
Und ja, der Typ ist halt auch irgendwie schon seit 12 Jahren weg oder so, der das mal programmiert hat.
Ich habe gesagt, ich fasse das freiwillig nicht an.
Wir können das zusammen anfassen, ja, mit dreifachem Durchschlag, dass ich nichts dafür kann, wenn es danach kaputt geht.
Aber ich fasse das nicht an.
Was heißt?
Ganz im Ernst, wer weiß, was da für Magic unter der Haube am Start ist.
Xeroxino, danke für den Sub.
Du hast jetzt einen Bug in der Software oder sollst ein neues Feature hinzufügen und musst halt diesen Code erstmal selbstständig verstehen.
Und das kann, ehrlich gesagt, manchmal schon so ein bisschen nervig auch sein.
Ja.
Und häufig ist es sogar so, gerade wenn du in einer sehr kleinen Firma bist, dass du der einzige bist, der bei gewissen Sachen versteht, um was es eigentlich geht.
Und deswegen kann es halt auch mal sein,
dass du jetzt beispielsweise am Abend oder wenn du im Urlaub bist, angerufen wirst.
Wenn du das nicht willst, dann solltest du das unbedingt schon ganz am Anfang mit deinem Arbeitgeber klarstellen.
Ich zum Beispiel...
Oder einfach nicht ans Telefon gehen.
Ich habe das selber schon gehabt, dass ich in Ägypten jetzt beispielsweise auf...
Also wenn man im Urlaub ist.
Also ganz im Ernst, wenn man...
Also ich gehe auch ans Telefon dran.
Ich bin nicht so.
Also wenn mich irgendjemand anruft, von unserem First Level oder sonst wie, auch abends.
Allein schon, weil ich die nicht da im Regen stehen lassen will.
Ich gehe da in der Regel dran.
Aber wenn ich wirklich in Ägypten im Urlaub wäre,
dann würde ich schlicht und ergreifend nicht ans Handy gehen.
Da sollen die sich um ihren eigenen Krempel kümmern.
Gerade irgendein super kritischer Fehler in der App war, angerufen wurde
und da musste ich halt auf dem Kamel jetzt Kunden Support machen.
Das stelle ich mir auch vor.
Deswegen, wenn du in einer kleinen Firma bist und vielleicht der einzige bist, der sich auskennt,
kann es halt sein, dass egal, ob du jetzt gerade den Mount Everest besteigst oder...
Die Basics machen erstmal.
...dass du halt immer deinen Laptop dabei hast.
Erstmal die Basics.
Das musst du einfach im Hinterkopf behalten und halt auch bei deiner Entscheidung mit abwägen.
Nee, das würde ich nicht machen.
Also das würde ich wirklich nicht machen.
Also wenn ich Bergstein gehe, würde ich weder ans Handy gehen, noch den Laptop.
Also wenn ich im Urlaub bin, dann würde ich nicht dran gehen.
Es sei denn, ich bin eh daheim und sitze vorm Rechner.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Aber ansonsten, nee, das würde ich nicht machen.
Also irgendwann ist auch mal gut.
Muss jeder für sich selbst wissen, wie er das handhaben will.
Aber ich meine, es sei denn, die bezahlen mich in irgendeiner Art und Weise dafür
und nicht bezahlen einfach nur für den Einsatz, wenn dann wirklich mal einer anruft,
sondern die müssen mich wirklich quasi...
dafür bezahlen, wenn ich im Urlaub immer bereit wäre, da ans Handy zu gehen.
Aber das will ich nicht.
Man soll sich im Urlaub auch erholen.
Klar, wenn ich eh daheim bin und sitze vorm Rechner, kann man das mal machen.
Und normalerweise gehe ich auch dran.
Aber wenn ich wirklich irgendwo wegfahren würde in den Urlaub,
da würde ich im Leben nicht dran gehen.
Gleich zum nächsten Fehler.
Das Management in Europa hat einfach kein Verständnis...
Das stimmt.
...für die Arbeitsweise von Programmierern.
Nicht nur für Programmierern.
Generell, was IT betrifft,
was Funktionsweise angeht,
sei es jetzt Programmieren,
das kann aber auch sein,
dass es um Abläufe auf Linux-Systemen geht,
generell um Technik an sich.
Da habe ich auch den Eindruck,
da tut sich das Management bei uns.
Und ja, ich würde tatsächlich sagen,
ich weiß nicht, ob es Europa ist,
aber tatsächlich ein deutschlandweites Problem ist.
Wisst ihr übrigens, warum Startups in Deutschland
die letzten Jahre immer so erfolgreich waren?
Habe ich letztens was Witziges drüber gelesen.
Ist wahrscheinlich eine Recycle-Story,
habe ich wahrscheinlich schon erzählt.
Und zwar nicht etwa,
weil die Startups gegründet haben,
die super krass innovatives neues Zeug machen,
sondern nein,
weil die Startups,
also die richtig erfolgreichen Startups,
anscheinend eben gerade dies nicht machen.
Und zwar haben die sich darauf fokussiert,
alten, uralt-Boomer-geführten Unternehmen
eben zu helfen,
den Anschluss wieder ein bisschen herzustellen
an die neue Technik.
Also sprich,
was weiß ich,
wir lösen das Fax ab oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Das musst du dich überlegen.
Also nicht wegen krasser Innovation,
sondern hauptsächlich wegen,
es gibt genug Boomer-Unternehmen,
die komplett den Anschluss verloren haben,
was IT angeht.
Wenn du quasi in Wuns oder in den USA arbeitest,
dann würde mich echt mal deine Meinung interessieren,
ob das bei dir genauso ist.
Gebe ihm aber recht.
In Europa ist es einfach so,
dass die meisten Manager nicht verstehen,
dass es keine bugfreie Software gibt.
Das nicht.
Und was die meisten Manager
beziehungsweise sehr viele Leute nicht verstehen,
auch BWL,
also generell BWL-Leute
oder Personalleute
oder Ressourcenplanungsleute,
was es nicht alles gibt,
also man könnte,
ja sagen wir Management,
die verstehen nicht,
dass Programmieren
eine kreative Angelegenheit ist.
Das ist nichts wie,
ich stehe jetzt am Fließband
oder wobei,
Fließband ist blöd.
Was weiß ich.
Das ist nicht wie,
ich schraube jetzt nach dem Plan
immer das exakt gleiche Teil zusammen
und sowas.
Programmieren ist was Kreatives
und kreative Sachen kannst du schlecht machen
unter Druck.
Und unter Angst und Stress schon mal gar nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst ein paar rudimentäre Sachen machen,
klar,
wenn das eigentlich fertig ist,
ja,
du kannst dann mit ein bisschen
trial and error
und ein paar Sachen probieren,
das wieder hinbiegen,
okay,
alles klar.
Aber du kannst,
wenn du Angst hast,
Stress hast,
dir,
was weiß ich,
im Zweifelsfall,
wenn du sogar noch,
nicht, dass es bei mir vorkommt,
ich sage bloß,
weil es bei manchen so ist,
dass der Chef die Leute anschreit,
der kann nicht erwarten.
Du kannst nicht sagen,
jetzt programmier endlich mal ordentlich weiter.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das klappt nicht.
Ja,
das muss eine ruhige Umgebung sein.
Das muss irgendwie auch gewisse kreative Atmosphäre zulassen.
Und,
ähm,
ja,
das ist wie,
wenn du zu einem Komponist sagen würdest,
ähm,
du musst dich jetzt mitten auf die Kreuzung setzen
oder die schreit einer an
oder,
ähm,
du bist im Riesen,
du bist,
keine Ahnung,
in der Schiffsschaukel,
du wirst im Kreis gedreht
oder was auch immer
und jetzt komponier mal irgendwie
neue Musik,
ja.
Das,
das funktioniert ja nicht.
Also du musst die Leute in Ruhe lassen
und musst man einfach mal anerkennen,
dass das,
wo ich auch denke,
dass das Management damit
an vielen Stellen Probleme hat,
dass Programmieren eine kreative Angelegenheit ist.
Und wie gesagt,
nicht nur Programmieren.
Vieles in der IT ist was,
wo man eine gewisse Art von Kreativität braucht,
weil es letztendlich um Problemlösung geht.
Und Problemlösung ist halt einfach immer ein weit
Kreativität gefragt.
Das heißt,
es ist halt ganz normal,
dass wenn du eine Software veröffentlichst,
dass da,
dass immer der eine oder andere kleine Fehler drin ist.
Ja,
kannst du nichts machen.
Es wird immer eine Sache gegeben.
Und wenn du die Sache in C++ programmierst,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich schon ab der zweiten Zeile fehlerhaft.
Oder ein Sonderfall,
wo deine App nicht perfekt funktioniert.
Und das ist einfach ganz normal.
Und das muss auch kontinuierlich dann immer gefixt werden.
Da muss kontinuierlich dran gearbeitet werden.
Und Methoden müssen kontinuierlich neu ein bisschen verbessert
und neu geschrieben werden.
Das Ganze heißt Refactoring,
wenn du dich schon ein bisschen besser auskennst.
Und gerade jetzt ohne irgendjemanden
zu nahe zu treten,
aber wenn dein Manager jetzt BWLer ist oder Ingenieur.
Ja,
die sind dann der Meinung,
so nach dem Motto,
ah ja gut,
dann ist das jetzt fertig,
dann kannst du jetzt was anderes machen.
So wie Dice Mabel für 2042.
So nach dem Motto,
das ist fertig,
das ist jetzt live.
Ja,
dann machen wir jetzt das Nächste.
Da muss man nichts mehr dran machen.
Gut,
bin ich bin froh,
dass ich in dem Fall,
also dass ich nicht Vollzeit Software Entwickler bin.
Aber das,
wie sagt man heute so schön,
das fühle ich.
Ja,
häufig nicht verstehen,
dass es keine bugfreie Software gibt.
Oder,
oder am besten,
sind auch so tolle Fehlerbeschreibungen wie,
oh,
das System ist heute aber ganz schön langsam.
Dann sagst du,
ja konkret,
was machst du?
Was ist genau langsam?
Ach,
das ist in letzter Zeit immer so oft.
Das System ist immer so langsam.
Ja,
um welches System geht es eigentlich jetzt genau?
Es ist teilweise der Wahnsinn,
mit was du dich da auseinandersetzen musst.
Eine andere Sache,
gerade in Europa,
ist halt das hier,
was ich dir jetzt einblende.
Diese Stellenanzeige ist definitiv von jemandem geschrieben.
Mensch,
der nicht genau weiß,
was er sucht.
Hier werden so viele verschiedene Technologien.
Okay,
zeig mal hier.
die Stellenanzeige ist wirklich gut.
Die ist wirklich gut.
Qt,
QML,
Golang,
JavaScript.
Das ist eine geile Stellenanzeige,
Alter.
Web Frameworks,
Angular React,
Terraform,
Azure,
Azure DevOps,
Linux Bash,
Clipping,
Kubernetes Docker.
Okay,
das ist gut.
Das ist eine geile Anforderungsliste.
Also,
leider habe ich die nicht gefunden.
Die hätte ich definitiv in irgendeinem Stellenanzeigen-Video schon eingebaut.
Also,
man muss ja mal,
ich versuche das mal ein bisschen zu erklären.
Also,
das sind alles mehr oder weniger komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Qt ist ein Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework.
QML ist im Endeffekt das Markup für Qt,
für die Oberfläche zu designen.
Golang ist eine komplett andere Programmiersprache,
als was du in der Regel für Qt verwendest.
Das heißt ja Qt,
heißt das eigentlich.
Also Qt machst du eigentlich in C++ oder eben in QML,
JavaScript,
aber hat nichts mit Golang zu tun.
Bindings gibt es,
aber macht eigentlich keiner.
So, also das ist was anderes.
Das impliziert auch,
dass du eigentlich C++ kannst.
Golang wieder was anderes.
JavaScript eher Frontend-mäßig noch was ganz was anderes.
Außer vielleicht Node-Backend wäre wieder was ganz anderes.
Web-Frameworks wie Angular oder React.
Man kann es davon abgesehen,
dass das schon mal zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe sind.
Web-Frameworks gibt es 50.000 verschiedene.
Ja, also,
und vor allem soll ich jetzt Desktop-UIs machen
oder was genau soll ich machen?
Terraform,
Azure CLI,
Azure DevOps,
okay,
das geht minimal wenigstens in die gleiche Richtung,
ist aber trotzdem was anderes.
Terraform ist eine,
wie nennt man es so schön,
Infrastructure-as-Code-Plattform,
wo du zum Beispiel einstellst,
ich hätte jetzt gerne 10 Linux-Server.
Azure CLI ist ein Kommandozeilen-Tool,
um Azure Ressourcen zu verwalten und anzulegen
und Azure DevOps ist was,
was eigentlich kein Mensch heute richtig verwenden will.
Es sei denn, man verwendet es schon.
Also der Trend geht eher Richtung GitHub
und GitHub Actions,
aber gibt es auch.
So, dann hast du,
du sollst dich nicht mit Linux auskennen,
okay,
und dann dort aus irgendwelchen Gründen sollst du
Bash-Scripting,
das Komma ergibt keinen Sinn, machen.
Ähm,
okay,
Linux und Bash-Scripting-Kenntnisse als Zusatz,
zum Beispiel zwar Terraform,
Azure CLI,
das ergibt ja Sinn.
Da sind wir eher so im Server-Admin,
DevOps,
äh,
Sys,
Sys-Admin-Bereich
hier,
ähm,
unterwegs,
da könnte man vielleicht auch ein bisschen Docker
und ein bisschen Kubernetes dazu,
das macht schon Sinn,
aber gerade das hier oben sind komplett unterschiedliche
paar Sachen.
Das hier ist quasi Desktop,
GUI-Entwicklung,
eventuell Mobile,
aber eher Desktop,
das hier ist wahrscheinlich Server-Backend-Entwicklung,
das hier ist Frontend oder Node-Backend,
also Server-Backend-Entwicklung,
das ist Frontend-Entwicklung
und das hier ist Infrastructure,
beziehungsweise Sys-Admin-Gedöns
und das hier halt Cloud-Native,
supermoderner Buzzword-Shit,
genau.
Also,
was eine blödsinnige Anzeige.
Ja,
das sind ziemlich gut drei Jobs auf einmal,
ja.
Was schreiben die sonst noch hin?
Du kennst dich in testgetriebene Entwicklung,
Continuous Deployment,
Testautomation und verteilte Versionskontrolle,
Git,
sehr gu aus.
Ja,
kann man,
kann man eigentlich so stehen lassen.
Ähm,
die Sache ist halt die,
weil wenn du,
wenn da solche Begriffe um sich geworfen werden,
ja,
aber
es ist trotzdem immer relativ interessant zu wissen,
mit was genau,
ja,
ist es irgendein old school Jenkins-Kram,
ist es vielleicht Drone oder so,
oder ist es,
ist es GitHub Actions,
oder ist es GitLab,
CI,
was auch immer.
Ähm,
das ist dann,
weil man kann das so pauschal zwar sagen,
ja,
habe ich schon gemacht,
aber das heißt noch lange nicht,
dass man das mit den Produkten gemacht hat
oder Ahnung haben auf die Art und Weise,
wie die das machen.
Ähm,
du beherrschst die deutsche Sprache in Wort und Schrift,
Englisch verhandlungssicher in Schrift und Sprache,
also sehr gut,
sehr gut,
muss ich das beherrschen,
dann ist alles gut.
Tschuldigung,
ähm,
es fällt dir leicht,
Informationen und Erkenntnisse mit deinem Umfeld zu teilen.
Heißt das,
ich soll der Schwätzer in der Teeküche werden,
oder was?
Was sie damit meinen,
ist wahrscheinlich,
du kannst technische Angelegenheit gut und verständlich auch
nicht Technikern erklären.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Du arbeitest gerade mit deinen Inter,
Moment, was?
Du arbeitest gerne mit deinen interdisziplinären Teammitgliedern zusammen.
Sag mal,
wer hat denn das geschrieben?
Was ist das für eine Anzeige?
Zu,
zusammen,
das wird aber langsam ganz schön,
gut,
gut.
der bekommt
labeling Stichwort
Reduktionsver patient in Steve Jobs.
Ich meine wirklich,
gibt es irgendjemanden,
der,
zu moderieren hilft dem team dabei warum soll ich das machen wenn ich das also das passt ja
überhaupt nicht dazu entscheidungsprozesse zu gestalten und zu moderieren das muss ich nicht
machen das muss irgendein projektmanager machen ich meine klar ich kann meinen senf dazu geben
das ist finde ich eine wichtige sache dass man da eben leute diese entscheidenden input haben
aber man sollte sich nicht auf meine fähigkeit für entscheidungsprozesse und irgendwelche
organisation verlassen als frontend entwickler du entwickelst hands-on in der mentalität eines
full stack alter was ein dummes geschwätz da hat er sich wirklich eine gute da hat er sich wirklich eine
gute stellenanzeige ausgesucht du entwickelst du ich kann das gar nicht mehr richtig aussprechen
du entwickelst hands-on in der mentalität eines full stack entwickler was bitteschön ist die
mentalität eines full stack entwicklers das sollten sie mal etwas näher ausführen was sie
sich darunter vorstellen
ich meine das da oben ist tatsächlich sehr full das ist fullest stack hier oben das ist quasi von der desktop
entwicklung bis zur backend entwicklung bis zur frontend entwicklung bis zur cloud ressourcen linux
administration und kubernetes es ist alles dabei das ist complete stack das ist fullest stack
wobei du deine spezialisierte expertise für den erfolg des teams und das produkt ist das
ist das eine stellenanzeige aus einem random generator ist das eine random generator anzeige
damit könnte man glaube ich wirklich geld verdienen wenn man einen guten random generator für
stellenanzeigen programmiert stimmt es ist nicht random aber es liest sich wie aus dem
stellenanzeigen generator der anwender und das erfolgreiche produkt stehen bei dir ganz weit oben
seriously wisst ihr was bei mir ganz weit oben steht dass ihr mich ordentlich bezahlt wenn ich
diesen ganzen mist kennen soll aber ganz ehrlich das kann man ja mal vorheucheln wenn die das hören
wollen und mal was machen möchte warum nicht
ja gut da kennen sie mehr da sind wir ja generell die absoluten kings was agile methoden angeht wir
sind t-shaped und safe und itil und kanban und scrum und was nicht alles alles peter agile ist
am start da hat sich da ist kein franzose mehr da ist jetzt engländer also du weil er muss ja
auch gut englisch können du bringst erfahrung im bereich agiler methoden wie scrum und oder kanban
und in der defizit identifiziert dich mit dem agilen mindset das ist auch einfach so ein eine
hülle einfach so so eine leere hülle hingeworfen und zu sagen ja agiles mindset da verstehe die
jeder ein bisschen was anderes darunter wissen und kenntnisse über it im fahrzeug sind von vorteil ok
ich glaube da falle ich mit meinem opel agiler raus als die im fahrzeug also das meiste als
in meinem auto ist wenn ich an den zigarettenanzünder ein 24 volt zu 5 volt usb ladegerät anstöpsel und
mein iphone dann im auto liegt also das ist die meiste it die es darin gibt radio ist für mich
keine it ja ich meine ich habe agiles mindset ich fahre ein ziemlich agiles auto als ist es
12 volt keine ja 12 volt ich glaube dass ja 12 volt aber ansonsten was darfst du bei daimler tts erwarten
hat es das mit text to speech zu tun wahrscheinlich das wäre tts stimmt was hat das mit full stack zu
tun das ist er wusst das ist eine gute frage nix nix hat das mit full stack zu tun auf der anderen
seite ich mein angeblich laufen die panels im tesla spaceships spaceship mit javascript nicht
tesla im space x spaceship laufen die panels angeblich mit javascript also warum nicht auch
irgendwelche konsolen im auto
Aber die haben angeblich immer noch Backup-Schalter, was auch wichtig ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, könnt ihr euch das wirklich vorstellen?
Wir fliegen mit Elektronen zum Mond irgendwann.
Es gibt Sachen, die hätte ich mir auch nie erträumen können.
Wir fliegen mit JavaScript zum Mond.
Okay, wir gucken das Video weiter.
Also, die Stellenanzeige hat er sich wirklich eine gute Stellenanzeige rausgesucht,
weil die ist echt Hardcore-Paints-Champ.
...verlangt, die wahrscheinlich kein Mensch wirklich alle beherrscht.
Das ist in etwa so, wie wenn man jetzt einen Olympiasportler sucht,
der in fünf verschiedenen Disziplinen eine Goldmedaille hat.
Ein bisschen crazy ist auch, wenn du dann eine Stellenanzeige siehst,
wo steht, dass jemand...
Aber das ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich ein Grund, nicht Programmierer zu werden.
Das ist ein Grund, nicht zu Kack-Arbeitgebern zu gehen.
Oder vielleicht ist der Arbeitgeber ja sogar ganz gut.
Aber die Stellenanzeigen ist einfach nur Müll.
...sucht, der sieben Jahre Flutter-Erfahrung hat.
Flutter ist ein Framework, das gibt es erst seit 2017.
Wie soll da jemand sieben Jahre Erfahrung haben?
Du musst dich halt einfach darauf einstellen...
Ich habe aus irgendwelchen Gründen Flat Earths verstanden gerade.
Flutter, verstehe.
Ja, das sind wie die Leute, die sagen, 20 Jahre Kubernetes-Experience, so nach dem Motto.
...Karriere als ITler, dass du Leuten, die nicht so Ahnung von der IT-Welt haben,
die IT-Welt erklären musst.
Und ganz wichtig ist auch, wenn du solche Stellen siehst,
wie beispielsweise dieses Flutter-Ding, bewirb dich einfach trotzdem.
Weil die Stelle, die da gesucht wird, die existiert ja offensichtlich nicht.
Und jetzt gibt es noch einen dritten Punkt, den ich gerne besprechen möchte.
Um einen Job als Programmierer zu bekommen, musst du halt auch richtig gut coden können.
Ich zweifle da manchmal dran, ob das wirklich so ist.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, gerade wenn ich bei uns so rumgucke, was da fabriziert wird.
Wichtig ist, dass du ein paar Leute hast, die gut programmieren können.
Das ist nicht komisch.
Das geht komplett in die Hose.
Aber dass der 0815 Softwareentwickler wirklich gut im Programmieren ist und im Entwickeln,
gut, was definiert man als gut?
Man könnte ganz ehrlich sagen, der ist Profi, der verdient damit Geld.
Also kann er ja nicht so schlecht sein.
Also ich meine das nicht in dem Video, sondern jemand, der Softwareentwickler ist.
Aber ich habe schon Dinge gesehen teilweise, wo ich mich wirklich frage,
was ist da los?
Ich habe es auch schon oft erzählt.
Mir fällt jetzt leider kein richtig schön griffiges Beispiel ein.
Ja, doch, zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel.
Okay, ich gebe zu, hat nicht direkt was mit Programmieren zu tun.
Aber letztens hat mir auch ein Entwickler voller Überzeugung erzählt,
das Zertifikat läuft doch gar nicht ab.
Warum sollte das ausgetauscht werden?
Das ist bis 2058 gültig.
Und was hat er gemeint?
Ja, das Zertifikat der CA ist bis 2058 oder bis 2038 gültig.
Nicht das eigene Zertifikat.
Das ist das eigentliche Zertifikat, was wir verwenden.
Aber das hat er voller Überzeugung da verteidigt, dass das so ist.
Und ähnliche Dinge laufen da an vielen Stellen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich gut sind alle.
Auch das ist tatsächlich ein Nachteil.
Also wir reden ja die ganze Zeit auf diesem Kanal darüber,
wie man als Quereinsteiger einen gut bezahlten Job als Programmierer bekommt.
Zur Wahrheit gehört allerdings auch, dass du das nur schaffen wirst,
wenn du wirklich gut programmieren kannst.
Viele Dinge, die du nicht tun kannst, sind nur für dich.
Viele denken ja die ganze Zeit, dass man hier jetzt irgendwie ein paar YouTube-Videos guckt,
ein paar Tutorials macht.
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht so.
Und schon bist du eine richtig gut gefragte Fachkraft, die 60.000 Euro verdient im Jahr.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du jetzt Programmierer werden möchtest und da einen guten Job mitfällst...
Und wann ist das Video? Also mit der aktuellen Platz...
Okay, okay.
Ist ein bisschen her.
Dann brauchst du halt einfach auch ein richtig gutes Portfolio an Projekten.
Oder, oder, oder, oder du wirst Kobol-Entwickler.
Da findest du ja immer was.
Du musst wirklich beweisen können, dass du gut programmieren kannst.
Und wenn du jetzt nicht gerade einen Masterabschluss in Informatik hast, sondern wirklich Quereinsteiger bist,
dann musst du noch mal ein bisschen mehr beweisen, dass du wirklich gut programmieren kannst.
Und das ist auch alles möglich.
Das haben wir schon mehrfach bewiesen und das beweisen auch andere Bootcamps Tag für Tag.
Und jeden Tag bekommt ein Programmierer irgendwo in Deutschland einen Job, der Quereinsteiger ist.
Also wenn du einfach nur ein bisschen Coden lernst, ist das einfach keine Job-Garantie.
Nein, du musst wirklich richtig solide coden können und dann musst du auch noch lernen, dass du gut programmierst.
Ja klar, also ich mein, wenn du ein paar mal Hello World programmiert hast, wird das nix.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wo einer bei uns mal erzählt hat, er hat irgendwie tolle VMware-Experience und am Ende kam raus, das ist jetzt kein Spaß, war wirklich so.
Am Ende kam raus, da hat Ubuntu irgendwo mal einen VMware installiert und meinte halt hier tolle, tolle VMware-Experience.
Da haben wir auch gedacht, was zum Teufel?
Ja.
Und die Krone...
Die Krone hat ja immer noch der Typ für die Cloud damals aufgesetzt, der uns nicht erzählen wollte, was er in seiner angeblichen Mathe-Abschlussarbeit von seinem Studium gemacht hat als Projekt.
Das habe ich euch, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Also wir hatten mal einen, der hat sich beworben und der hat angeblich Mathe studiert und dann wurde er gefragt im Vorstellungsgespräch, ja, was haben Sie, mit was hat sich denn Ihr...
Ich glaube sogar, der hat ein Diplom angeblich gehabt.
Mit was hat sich denn quasi so Ihre Mathe-Abschlussarbeit, ich kenne mich bei dem nicht genau aus, wie das läuft, aber ich nenne es jetzt einfach Abschlussarbeit, also sprich, was war denn Ihr Projekt, also was haben Sie denn gemacht?
Und da hat er dann darauf geantwortet und hat gesagt, ha, eigentlich darf ich darüber nicht reden, kann ja sein, wirkt aber schon ein bisschen sass, ja, wirkt schon ein bisschen shady, aber es gibt ja Projekte, wo man wirklich nicht so im Detail drüber reden darf.
Ja.
Aber, ja gut, aber so grob, mit was haben Sie sich denn beschäftigt?
Und er meinte, er hat sich beschäftigt mit der, ich kriege es wirklich nicht mehr zusammen, irgendwie mit der, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, mit der dritten Vermutung von Mathematiker XY.
Ja, mit irgendwas, was irgendjemand aufgestellt hat und er hat das dann irgendwie weiter analysiert und das Problem war nur, der Typ hat damit richtig massiv ins Klo gegriffen bei einem.
Ja.
Weil in diesem Vorstellungsgespräch saß wahrscheinlich der Einzige im Umkreis von, na gut, in Frankfurt haben wir eine Uni und sonst wie, aber ich sage mal, der Einzige im Umkreis von 100 Kilometern, der wusste, wovon der Typ spricht und dann hat der Typ ihn gefragt im Vorstellungsgespräch, ha, die zweite Vermutung von dem kenne ich aber, sagen Sie mal, was genau ist denn die dritte Vermutung?
Erkennen Sie mal.
Und das wurde dann leider etwas peinlich und zumindest nur mal so als Hintergrund, als Hintergrund, warum der Typ das wusste.
Also wir hatten mal einen, der hat sich um, ja, der hat sich, ich nenne es mal ein bisschen als Projektkoordinator versucht, aber eigentlich war der Mathematiker durch und durch und das war ein richtig krasser Typ, ja.
Ja.
Und der hat nämlich in seiner Freizeit im Prinzip, ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, wie sich das nennt, aber ich sage es jetzt mal in meinen Worten, der ist quasi nur noch arbeiten gegangen, damit er über die Runden kommt, dass er sich in seiner Freizeit mit ungelösten mathematischen Problemen beschäftigen kann.
Der war da auch in irgendeinem Mathematikerkreis aktiv und hat dann auch irgendwelche Vorträge gehalten und alles.
Also das war ein richtig krasser Pfeifhead-Mathematiker.
Ja.
Und eigentlich ist das das, was er nach Möglichkeit hauptberuflich machen will, aber wahrscheinlich ist das nicht so einfach möglich.
Und der hat, man kann es denke ich so sagen, der hat einfach nur gearbeitet, um genug Geld zu haben, dass er genug Zeit hat, sich drumherum seinen mathematischen Problemen zu widmen.
Tja, man kann es versuchen, Scheiße zu erzählen.
Das hat in dem Fall aber nicht geklappt.
Da müsste ich mal ein Video drüber machen.
Mathe-Faker im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Also ob der jetzt nicht wirklich ein abgeschlossenes Studium hat, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber das, was er über seine Abschlussarbeit erzählt hat, war offensichtlich jebaited.
Hab ich schon mal erzählt?
Und dich auch in einem Bewerbungsgespräch richtig durchzusetzen.
Du musst also lernen, dich zu verkaufen.
Du musst einfach sagen, Jungs, ich gehe jetzt an die Tafel und inverte den Binary Tree.
Dann hast du das schon. Easy.
Und wenn du das alles kannst, dann findest du einen Job.
Und das Ganze ist natürlich auch in sechs Monaten erlernbar, aber das Ganze ist halt auch, ehrlich gesagt, richtig Arbeit.
Okay, also richtig gut ist, was man so in sechs Monaten mit wirklich Energie und Zeitaufwand lernen kann.
Das würde ich tatsächlich dann auch unterschreiben.
Also wenn es um dieses Niveau geht als Einsteiger, was, wenn du dich sechs Monate ransetzt und wirklich richtig...
...intensiv lernst, was du in sechs Monaten lernen kannst, hast du das quasi so als Junior dann...
Das ist okay, das verstehe ich.
Aber weil so diese Definition von richtig gut deckt sich halt nicht das, wie ich das bei nicht schlecht bezahlten Leuten bei uns sehe.
Du musst reinhauen.
Und der vierte Nachteil ist, dass Programmieren halt einfach nicht wirklich ein sozialer Job ist.
Das stimmt. Das ist doch kein Nachteil.
Wer sagt das?
Wer sagt, dass das ein Nachteil ist?
Das ist eines der besten Sachen da dran.
Den einen oder anderen vielleicht hart.
Aber wenn du gerne einen Job hast, wo du viel redest, wo du immer mit Kollegen unterwegs bist...
Ja, reden vielleicht, aber mit anderen Leuten muss es nicht sein.
...wenn du gerne Präsentationen hältst, dann ist...
Präsentationen halten mache ich tatsächlich ganz gerne mittlerweile.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein Teil auch YouTube zu verdanken.
Moin Patrick oder guten Abend.
Herr The Game 402.
Aber für mich ist das kein Nachteil.
Ich beschäftige mich nicht gerne mit Leuten.
Programmierer vielleicht nicht der richtige Job für dich.
Da hat er recht.
Also als Programmierer...
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch den sogenannten Bro-Krammer, der mit allen richtig krass Bro ist.
Bostrott, danke für den Sub.
Aber in der Regel würde ich sagen, Leute, generell Leute, die in die IT gehen, nicht nur Programmierer,
die wollen in der Regel lieber mit Technik arbeiten, als...
Also mit Technik arbeiten.
...mit irgendwelchem sozialem Kram.
...muss halt häufig haben, dass du mal so vier Stunden oder so am Stück an deinem Schreibtisch sitzt,
dicke Noise cancels in den Kopfhörer auf und nichts anderes machst, als zu programmieren.
Ja, okay.
Nichts anderes zu programmieren bedeutet im Prinzip 50% googeln.
Aber das gehört ja dazu.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit noch mehr als sonst, dass du halt auch häufig sehr viel Homeoffice machst.
So muss das sein.
Wenn du jetzt alleine wohnst oder vielleicht noch jung bist und keine Familie hast,
dann kann das manchmal auch vielleicht für den einen oder anderen nervig sein, sehr viel zuhause zu hocken.
Nein, ich finde das gut.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du nicht mehr das...
Deswegen gehe ich auch jetzt immer 1-2 Stunden, war eher 2 Stunden mittlerweile, ja wandern am Tag oder bisschen laufen.
Einfach als Ausgleich.
Und das bringt unglaublich viel.
Hätte ich mir das selbst vor 15 Jahren gesagt, hätte ich gesagt, Max Keck, weh, was erzählst du für einen Schwachsinn.
Nie so ein Problem.
Also mir hat das Spaß gemacht, auch mal ein paar Stunden alleine zu hocken, aber...
Ich finde das super.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn du...
Lass mir die Ruhe.
...jetzt ein sehr extrovertierter Typ bist, der sehr viel gerne mit Leuten redet, dann kann man in so einem Job halt auch einfach unglücklich werden.
Das stimmt wohl.
Und dann kommen wir noch zum fünften Nachteil.
Da hat er nicht Unrecht, ja klar.
Aber die meisten Leute in der IT, glaube ich, gehen in die IT, weil sie nicht so viel mit Leuten zu tun haben wollen.
Programmieren ist eine lebenslange Herausforderung.
Das stimmt, das ist wirklich so.
Der Nachteil ist also ziemlich klar, wenn du jetzt eine Arbeit suchst...
Also generell, nicht nur Programmieren, Programmieren selbstverständlich auch.
Aber im Prinzip jeder IT-Job.
Ist eine lebenslange Herausforderung.
Oder du musst lebenslang dich auf dem aktuellen Stand halten.
Es gibt Gegenbeispiele, ja.
Von irgendeinem Mainframe-Programmierer, der seit 40 Jahren nichts anderes macht.
Okay, aber in der Regel ist das so.
Und das ist aber bei den meisten IT-Berufen so.
Es ist aber auch nicht nur bei IT-Berufen so.
Also ich bin mir sicher, kann ich jetzt natürlich nicht aus erster Hand sagen, aber ich bin mir sicher...
Es gibt genug andere Berufe, da ist das auch so.
Und ich denke auch, dass man...
Ich denke auch, dass man heutzutage nicht mehr sagen kann...
Hey, ich habe jetzt, was auch immer...
Keine Ahnung...
Schreiner oder irgendwie irgendwas Handwerkermäßiges gelernt.
Und kann dann mein Leben lang exakt den gleichen Kram machen.
Immer ohne mich irgendwie mal ein bisschen weiterzubilden.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so sein.
Ja, Medizin ist halt auch richtig krass.
Aber in der IT ist es natürlich auch ein Ding.
Du musst dich mit neuen Sachen auseinandersetzen.
Für mich ist das sogar gut.
Ich mache das gerne.
Ich meine, ich setze mich nicht umsonst hier in dem Stream hin und sage, morgen gucken wir uns beispielsweise Rust WebAssembly an.
Warum mache ich das?
Das mache ich nicht, weil ich wirklich denke, ich kriege irgendwie einen krasseren Job dadurch.
Sondern einfach, weil es mich interessiert.
Und ich mache so Sachen mittlerweile auch gerne im Stream.
Einfach, weil die Leute im Chat auch echt gute Ideen haben.
Wir haben jetzt schon ein paar Sachen hier im Stream gemacht, wo ich gesagt habe, Leute, ohne den Chat wäre ich da so nicht drauf gekommen.
Und ich habe mich eigentlich während dem Stream-Programm hier auf den Flieger geklappt.
Es gibt eine Kindheit, die sich macht, die sich gestaltet auf der Internetseite konzentriert.
Und dann kommt das Programmieren einfach einfach auf die Wörter.
Und ich mache mir jetzt einen Punkt vor.
Du machst dein Leben lang nur noch diesen einen Job und möchtest nichts neues mehr dazu lernen.
Dann ist Programmieren nicht das Richtige für dich.
Das stimmt.
Programmieren ist etwas, da kommen ständig neue Technologien raus.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, gerade im JavaScript-Bereich musst du ja quasi täglich.
Während dieses Video läuft, wurden 20 neue JavaScript-Frameworks erfunden.
Neue Programmiersprachen und die musst du lernen.
Du musst dich immer an die Umwelt anpassen, die sich ständig ändert.
Die muss man aber zum Glück nicht lernen.
Eben zum Beispiel, schon mal erwähnt,
Flutter ist ein Framework, das ist 2017
rausgekommen von Google.
Und damit macht man so native Apps und Websites.
Wisst ihr, was mich ja ein bisschen ärgert an Flutter
ist? Warum muss das unbedingt Dart sein?
Hätten die da nicht Go
nehmen können?
Da hätte man wenigstens eine ordentliche Library-Auswahl
gehabt, da hätte man wenigstens eine ordentliche
Auswahl. Aber Dart,
ist Dart
wenigstens kompatibel zu irgendwelchen
JavaScript-Libraries?
Ich hab mich damit noch nicht,
also außer diese Beispiel-App,
die wir mal gemacht haben im Stream,
falls sich noch jemand dran erinnert,
hab ich noch nie was mit Flutter gemacht, natürlich nicht, okay.
100 Bits, 100 Milliarden,
Dankeschön, EDV
Forensik.
Und alles mit einer Programmiersprache
und dieses Framework ist richtig
gut, ja, das macht richtig Spaß, damit zu
arbeiten, es ist sehr intuitiv, es ist
effizient, aber...
Findet ihr, Dart ist eine gescheite Programmiersprache
oder eher Crap?
Ich konnte mir da jetzt noch keine Meinung
drüber bilden.
Ob das jetzt in 10 Jahren noch relevant sein wird,
das kann ich nicht sagen. Da gibt es einfach keine
Garantie für. Toll, J-Lo, du hast
es doch noch nie verwendet.
Kommt nochmal eine komplett neue Programmiersprache,
die den Markt nochmal umwirft.
Deswegen muss man sich einfach immer
damit auseinandersetzen.
Ich hoffe, ich hab dich jetzt nicht zu sehr
abgeschreckt, Programmierer zu werden, also
ich muss sagen, ich programmiere ja inzwischen seit 15
Jahren und für mich ist das immer noch der beste Job,
den ich mir vorstellen kann. Ich liebe es
zu programmieren, mir macht es super
viel Spaß und wenn du jetzt wissen
möchtest, was die Vorteile am Programmierer
werden sind, dann kann ich dir hier nochmal...
War doch zum größten Teil richtig, was er gesagt hat,
ja. Man kann natürlich
die einzelnen Punkte immer diskutieren, aber
im Prinzip, ja, wenn du ein super extrovertierter Dude
bist, der den ganzen Tag irgendwie am liebsten
mit Leuten schwätzt, dann solltest du vielleicht lieber
in den Außendienst gehen.
Wenn ich mir ein bisschen Gedanken
drüber mache, wahrscheinlich hätte ich noch ein paar
andere Punkte, warum es keine gute Idee ist.
Da müsste ich mir tatsächlich mal Gedanken
drüber machen. Es gibt bestimmt noch mehr Punkte,
wo ich sagen würde, generell in die IT zu gehen, ist
keine so gute Idee. Aber
Management ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Punkt.
Gibt sicherlich noch
mehr Punkte. Da müsste ich
echt mal in mich gehen
und überlegen.
Also ein Punkt für mich, das trifft sich nicht so wirklich
mit Management, gerade in
größeren Unternehmen, so dieses ganze
Business Enterprise Umfeld
ist in vielen Bereichen
einfach Painstamp. Wenn du quasi
für eine 15
Minuten Angelegenheit
zwei Tage brauchst, weil es so viel
Bürokratie gibt,
so viel
Zwischenprozessschritte, so viele
Meetings und Cuprunden, wo du
das vorstellen musst und so viele
Leute, die dann im Prinzip dir auch noch auf den Nerven
gehen, gibt es ein Rollback-Verfahren.
Ich wurde ernsthaft mal gefragt,
ob es ein Rollback-Verfahren
gibt. Und wisst ihr, was wir machen wollten?
Wir wollten uns auf den Server einloggen
und ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, was es
war. Deswegen schmücke ich das mal
ein bisschen aus, aber es war was in dieser Richtung.
Du machst ein LS in einem Ordner
und dann guckst du ein paar
Textdateien nach Festplattenauslastung.
Das war's. Also wir wollten uns da drauf
einloggen auf dem Produktiv. Nach dem Motto, machen wir,
loggen wir uns ein, ziehen wir uns ab, dauert fünf Minuten,
gar kein Problem. Da wurde ich allen Ernstes mal
gefragt, gibt es ein Rollback-Verfahren?
Und ich wusste legit nicht,
was ich da drauf sagen soll.
Ich meine ernsthaft, was sagst du da drauf,
ob ein LS
ein Rollback-Verfahren hat?
Soll ich sagen, ja, ich scroll dann
im Terminal einfach wieder rauf, dann sieht's aus
wie vorher. Oder was willst du
da drauf sagen?
Marktlücke an
LS. Erstmal ein Snapshot
machen vor dem LS, so sieht's aus.
Also da
wusste ich damals wirklich nicht, was ich drauf
sagen sollte.
Und dann wurde ich gefragt, genau,
da hab ich gesagt, Rollback-Verfahren,
da passiert nichts,
das ist ein... Damals hab ich den
Fehler gemacht, ja. Damals hab ich gesagt, da passiert
nix. Das ist ein ganz normaler Standardbefehl,
der ist auf Linux dabei und
was soll dabei passieren? Und da war
halt noch so ein richtig nerviger Typ
dabei, der dann erzählt hat, haha,
famous last words, da kann ja gar nichts
dabei passieren. Haha.
Ihr kennt so Leute, die da dann irgendwie
einen Wahnsinns-Spaß draus machen müssen, so als sind sie
voll überlegen und blicken da jetzt durch.
Dabei hat der Typ absolut keinen blassen Schimmer gehabt,
was ich ihm gerade erzählt hab.
Und dann wurde ich
gefragt, ob ich die Gefahren-Matrix ausgefüllt
hab dafür. Das hab ich euch, glaube ich, auch schon
mal erzählt. Und dann haben wir
wirklich mal die Gefahren-Matrix ausgefüllt
für ein LS und
kein Rollback-Verfahren
und hast du nicht gesehen. Und
laut dieser Gefahren-Matrix kam dann raus,
dass ein... Auch kein
zwei Augen, kein, kein, nicht zwei Augen,
ähm, kein Vier-Augen-System
und sowas in der Richtung. Da kam dann damit
raus, dass theoretisch, wenn man diese Gefahren-Matrix
wirklich
gewissenhaft ausfüllt, ein LS
ein hochkritischer Change auf dem Server ist.
Und das sind so Dinger, wo ich mir sage,
das ist halt dieses Business-Enterprise-Umfeld,
was mir auf den Sack geht.
Ja.
Du hast vollkommen recht.
Du hast vollkommen recht. Das ist
tatsächlich, ähm,
eines der besten Sachen, was du
machen kannst. Du sagst, du musst
es halt ein bisschen anders, du musst es halt ein bisschen anders
verkaufen. Du musst sagen, ja gut,
wenn der Change zu risikoreich
ist, dann können wir den Change verschieben.
Wir können den Change auch sein lassen.
Wir müssen den Change ja nicht durchführen, aber dann
ist es halt so, dass in zwei Tagen,
was auch immer, das Zertifikat abläuft
und dann muss man halt sagen, da gibt es die und die Probleme,
aber wie gesagt, wir müssen den Change
nicht durchführen. Und was für eine Matrix
geht, ist Gefahren-Matrix.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es das als
im Prinzip tatsächlich
ein bisschen sowas.
Nur, dass es nicht um Angstreaktionen
geht. Also da gibt es dann zum Beispiel
eine Gefahren-Matrix, da stehen dann so Sachen wie
ähm, wie viele User sind
betroffen, ähm,
wie lange dauern die Wartungsarbeiten.
So, und wenn du das ausfüllst, dann kriegst du,
kannst du dann hier irgendwie ablesen,
wie kritisch das ist. Also quasi, wenn du hier
irgendwo rauskommst, ist es unkritisch, wenn du hier
irgendwie rauskommst, ist es mittel, und wenn du hier irgendwie rauskommst,
ist es superkritisch.
Und wir haben diese Gefahren-Matrix mal
gewissenhaft für ein LS ausgefüllt
und es kam ein hochsicherheit,
hochkritischer Change bei raus,
wo ich dann auch gesagt habe, Leute, ihr habt sie nicht mehr alle.
Ähm, ja, das ist
Sachen, die mir auch auf Kicks gehen,
an diesem Business Enterprise Umfeld.
Leider sind es dann die gleichen Leute,
die, wenn sie selbst was haben wollen,
weg gegen ihre eigenen Prozesse verstoßen.
Ja, das ist halt so dieses Business Enterprise
Umfeld, was mir ein bisschen auf den Sack geht.
Würdest du wieder ins Business Umfeld
gehen, im neuen Job oder in eine andere Richtung?
Ja, wenn ich mir, also mal
angenommen, mal angenommen, bei dieser Umstrukturierung
kommt jetzt wirklich raus,
ähm, ich muss kündigen, weil
wir kein Homeoffice mehr machen können, also gar
keins mehr, ähm, und ich
sag, gut, ich kündige, ich würde wahrscheinlich
erstmal gucken, dass ich
tatsächlich was ähnliches mache,
weil ich würde erstmal,
die Leute, die ich, äh,
die letzten Jahre über kennengelernt habe und
mit denen ich mich gut verstanden habe, von denen ich
auch von dem einen oder anderen noch
Kontaktdaten hätte, die würde ich einfach
mal fragen. Die würde ich einfach mal
fragen, sagt mal, Jungs, wie sieht's denn bei euch aus?
Ähm, lang nix gehört.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich erstmal nett sein
und sagen, lang nix gehört, wie sieht's aus?
Sucht ihr gerade Leute? Das wäre
wahrscheinlich das Erste, was ich machen würde. Ich würde mal
ein paar Leute anhauen. Und,
äh, ich gehe davon aus, dass wahrscheinlich an
vielen Stellen tatsächlich dann schon Leute gesucht werden.
Ja, mal gucken. Ja, aber
wahrscheinlich würde ich was in der Richtung machen,
weil es gerade in Frankfurt
auch relativ easy ist, weil wo
du hinguckst, ist ein Rechenzentrum, wo du hinguckst,
ist im Prinzip eine Bank oder irgendein
Finanzdienstleister. Und viele Finanzdienstleister
stehen drauf, das
weiß ich, weil meiner steht da auch
drauf, wenn die Leute schon Erfahrung
mit Finanzdienstleistern haben.
So ganz sicher,
warum, gerade im
IT-Umfeld, wenn man sich um
irgendwelche Sachen kümmert,
ja, was weiß ich, wenn die irgendjemand suchen
für Windows Active Directory,
warum der dann zwangsläufig Erfahrung im
Finanzdienstleistungsumfeld haben muss,
ich weiß es nicht,
ja, oder wenn man irgendwelche
Linux-Administratoren sucht oder
was auch immer, warum die dann
aber die mögen das. Also das kenne ich von
uns. Finanzdienstleister mögen,
dass man Leute Erfahrung mit Finanzdienstleister
haben. Die kennen
schon den Paintschamp, ja, das ist es
wahrscheinlich. Und
dementsprechend denke ich, dass das natürlich auch ein Bonus
ist, wenn ich sagen kann, ja, ich habe
jetzt
über 10 Jahre Erfahrung,
sind sogar noch mehr,
aber ich habe über 10 Jahre Erfahrung, was
IT im Finanzdienstleistungssektor
angeht.
Morgen frei? Nein, morgen nicht
frei. Ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
Ich muss ins Bett. Habt ihr gut erkannt,
Leute? Bett getimed.
Nein, wir gucken uns kein Video an,
das ist schon 2016.
Ähm,
korrekt. Das wäre für mich
auch wichtig. Also ich würde
nur noch, wenn es Homeoffice gibt,
nicht hundertprozentig Homeoffice, aber
ein Tag die Woche ist okay,
aber 80 Prozent, 90 Prozent
Homeoffice müssen sein.
Wo arbeitest du bei einer Bank? Korrekt, ja.
Richtig.
In Frankfurt, am Main. Da gibt's
viele Banken. Top.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das läuft.
Ich werde nichts weiter im Detail dazu erzählen,
bei welcher Bank. Die meisten Leute haben es ja eh schon
äh, also letztens,
letztens hat es einer geschrieben und der war
gar nicht so falsch, ja. Die Leute haben
sich das ja eher schon nach Ausschlussverfahren
zurechtgereimt mit der Zeit.
Also, wir sehen uns, Leute. Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
Was als Quereinsteiger, der keine richtige Entwicklerstelle findet,
als Test-Automation-Ingenieur-JavaScript-Einsteiger
legitim?
Ähm,
boah,
pauschal jetzt schwer zu sagen.
Ähm, also Entwicklererfahrung
ist natürlich gut, wenn es um
ähm,
im weiteren Sinne,
darum geht. Kann ich jetzt so auspauschal
nix, nix, nix zu sagen.
Der Patrick könnte es tatsächlich liegen. Der Patrick
weiß es nämlich.
Und, und wisst ihr, was das Bittere
ist an dieser ganzen Sache?
Der Patrick hat
einen Kumpel, der hat sich beworben
bei, sagen wir mal was,
bei einem Dienstleister, so aus unserem
Dunstkreis und wurde letztendlich
auch genommen. Und ich konnte
kein Mitarbeiter-Werben-
Mitarbeiter-Programm
geltend machen dafür. Das ist bitter.
Sonst hätte ich ein paar, hätte ich,
weiß gar nicht, was es bei uns da
mittlerweile für gibt, aber leider
nicht. Leider ging das nicht.
Sonst hätte ich direkt Mitarbeiter-Werben-Mitarbeiter
abgegriffen, aber es war, es war
leider nicht möglich. Patrick, weißt
du, ob der immer noch dort arbeitet?
Vielleicht habe ich den ja
sogar schon mal gesehen und ich weiß gar nicht, dass das
ist. Und er weiß nicht, dass ich das
bin. Kann ja
sein. Das war richtig sad,
gell, ja. Massive sad, gell.
Der ist noch da, okay.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Stream. Bis
morgen. Morgen Rust WebAssembly.
Irgendwann Nachmittag, wenn ich mein
Sportprogramm hinter mir
habe. Also, wir sehen uns. Bis dann. See you.